[Music]
n
day two of the match of the Millennials
here in St Louis the capital of Chess in
the US the roller coaster ride continued
as the game's Future Stars cross swords
once again on the chess world's
brightest stage the young USC bisara ASA
continued to shine as she won a second
game in a row but American Phenom
Karissa Yip managed to win a wild game
in a marathon 112 moves to even the
score for the girls in the competition
but it was Australian Anton smov scoring
an upside victory of the higher rated
Sam seon that helped turn the tables in
favor of the World Squad who now hold a
solid two-point lead at the midpoint of
the event can the US make a bid for a
comeback against a focus and determined
world team day three of live action
coming up
next
[Music]
hello and welcome back everybody to day
three of the 2017 match of the
Millennials an unprecedented clash
between the top juniors in the United
States against the top juniors in the
world yesterday we've seen the world
play brilliant chess and they now have
the commanding lead they lead by two
points but the top Junior in the United
States will be guns blazing today and
hopefully we're going to be able to see
a nice comeback let's go to the studio
because we have a surprise for you and
start the
day hello everyone welcome to the 2017
match of the Millennials my name is t
Abraham and I'm in the studio with
Alejandra Ramirez and today we'll bring
you the action from round five on day
three of the tournament well it has been
a very interesting match so far but I
have to say a little bit disappointing
for the US so far I thought they would
be much more dominant in the under 17
section and instead of winning they're
actually down a game in a section that
they're considerably higher rated in I
completely agree I thought the US team
would be dominating in the under 17
section uh they have Jeffrey Jang the
current world junior Champion they have
Sam savian who's won pretty much every
tournament he's been playing in this
year and I thought under 17 section was
for us to take and under 14 section was
the one they would be struggling in but
see that's not the case and um I think
they need to really step up their game
to make a comeback and even try to win
this tournament as we do have half of
the tournaments still left yeah let's
see what happened yesterday actually uh
in precisely in the under 17 section so
we had Nicholas Czech win against hike
marosan of Armenia after that horrible
blunder that we saw John Berg lost to
Andre yeno Sam saan also lost to Anon
smov after um another blunder very
shocking blunder where he uh turned turn
things around for his opponent and
Jeffrey Jan who had the advantage and
was pressing for a long time did not
manage to convert Andrew Alex run and
now the score of the match is 7 7 and 1
half to 8 and A2 where the world team is
leading by a full point yeah definitely
not a situation you want to be in it's
only the halfway point plenty of time
for us to make up the Lost ground but
they have to start soon they have to
start winning some key matchups they
have to start pushing with the white
pieces and these blunders that we've
been seeing honestly from both teams
cannot keep happening yeah and you
mentioned uh pressing with the white
pieces and that's a very big U thing to
consider in a team tournament and I I
think we do see a lack of experience as
Sam savan drew a quick game like 17
moves with the white pieces and in a
team tournament you're just not allowed
to do that because you're putting your
team at such a disadvantage with two
blacks they're going to be struggling
because no matter who you're playing
having to Black pieces left it's a very
tough thing to do right so I think
that's uh I want to say a little
irresponsible to the team but it's
mainly lack of experience lack of
experience I agree completely well let's
take a look at the format of the
tournament and see uh what's going on
here so we do have a shingan system a
shingan system is when everyone on the
team is playing everyone on the opposing
team so we do have a double Shing again
so we have eight games and we're in the
second half of the tournament which
means everyone will be playing everyone
in Reverse colors and the time control
is still classical chest but a little
faster paced it's gaming 90 plus 30
second in but there is no second time
control yeah that second time control
the players are very used to it's the
more common time control around the
world the US Championship uses it many
other tournaments at the highest level
use this time control with a 30 minute
increment on move 40 it doesn't exist
here it makes the game much faster pced
you don't want to be living on increment
for many hours we saw what happened
yesterday in the game uh of Karissa J
112 moves of Chess two hours played
entirely on increment and blunders a
blaze simply because playing on such
pressure is very very difficult even at
the highest level uh it is uh that did
happen and it does happen when you have
increment but I do prefer this time
control especially when you have two
rounds a day because it does give you
some time to recover and uh I think it's
just more fun to play this way because
if you're a Time trouble addict it's
going to happen anyway so you might as
well get to it faster uh let's go to
Christian and he will tell us about the
key match up for today thanks guys and
good morning everyone welcome back to
day three of the 2017 match of the
Millennials what an exciting match we
have on our hands and today is going to
be very very combative because it's an
important match for the United States if
they want to manage to pull the comeback
let's look at the top performance in
both uh teams in the Juniors of the
United States we have Jeffrey Shong Sam
seian uh both leading the team but Ru
Fang Lee is struggling and we'll see if
he will be able to come back and win
today against Arian Chopra in the world
team we have Andre esipenko and Anon
smov leading the very very powerful and
combative world team right now the
overall score is plus two for the world
team and we'll see if Sam seian who is
battling in the match of the day uh he's
battling Andre aseno this is going to be
an explosive affair both these players
have very wild styles and uh we're going
to see who's going to come on top this
is going to be a very very exciting
round guys that's it and let's remember
that perhaps the viewers are wondering
why don't they match up why has Sean
played more games than esipenko and
remember that we have alternates here on
the teams so esipenko hasn't played all
of his games while Sean has and actually
I am very surprised at who the world
team is uh setting out on this important
round yeah let's take a look at the
pairings uh in the rest of the section
so we have hi marosan playing Jeffrey
Jan Andre yeno playing Sam savian Arian
Chopper playing ruang Lee and Alexa San
versus Nicholas CA and I do agree with
you that smna won that important game
against Sam savian and I guess once you
b s saan you deserve a rest yeah very
surprising for me the top scorer of uh
the world team is resting in such a
crucial round today uh we're going to
have to see if our players with white
the higher rated players Jeffree strong
and Sam Sean now with the white pieces
can prove how strong they are and win
their games here to try to take an
advantage yeah I think we've reached the
point when uh draws are just not enough
you have to win and um I I don't think
we're at a point when you have to win
big you just have to win a match right
and it has to start turning the ties
actually the US team hasn't won a single
one of the under 17 matches we had three
draws in the first three matches and we
were were minus one yesterday as we were
looking at earlier as we see the players
getting ready for it's going to be round
five here of the match of the
Millennials and I think actually the US
team is lucky to only be losing by two
points because yes um no day one of the
under 14 section I think at some point
us was set to lose 4- Zer definitely at
some point that looked really bad but
kudos to Mar sades she saved a
completely lost end game and actually
well thanks to I mean I cannot say could
when your opponent just Flags but you
know point point but she did save the G
game which is really important but by
the time that her opponent flaged she
had already saved a half point which to
me had been an enormous breakthrough in
the end game uh but it's true that at
some point games looked really bad in
the first game in the under 14 and not
that much better yesterday honestly yeah
it's very stressful playing in a team
tournament because I've played many
Olympiad and sometimes when you're
playing like a lower rated team or what
for these players in under 14 section
there's some Randomness still because
they are so young and they're not used
to playing in a team event so I I can
understand why there's this Randomness
factor I remember I played many Olympiad
and at some point you're looking around
like especially if you're playing board
two or three so you have people next to
you you're not board one when you have
only one person and then you look around
and you see one person is losing the one
person is worse you're like oh my God
what's going on like we're losing in
round one and this has happened to me
like I'm Olympians I remember once I
looked over and I said my I forgot who
was playing next te and there King was
like in the middle of the board I was
like what's going on this is round one
well I like how we casually throw that
out you know we play you know few
Olympiad here and there casual
representing America of course as we see
Sam seian who is he's running a little
bit behind but let's remember this is
the future of Chess in America Sam savan
and Jeffrey Shong are the top 16y old
players not only in the country but in
the entire world so we have really high
hopes for both of them yeah definitely
definely and Sam savan he's not having a
great tournament here but he's been
having a great year so far so I don't
think this's one tournament or than one
actually it's not even one game that one
blunder is a representative of his chess
because um happens to everybody yeah no
he started uh guns blazing two z uh
yesterday he didn't have a great day
it's brought his tournament back but
let's see if he can recover this today's
struggling with his
clock already off to a bad start let's
see if he can recover he has white
pieces here against and
he cannot do what he did yesterday which
was just pretty much a blunder away his
advantage against Sana and he had to
just draw in 17 moves as you mentioned
in the team tournament that is much less
acceptable than it is in an individual
one yeah and we do see the lack of
experience and I do think the world team
has better experience at this or at
least I think maybe they have a better
team Dynamic I think they have a better
understanding of what needs to be done
in a team and I don't I don't think us
team does Ru fanglee is just simply
struggling and he's a power house but
unfortunately he's not scoring any
points and that's dragging uh the whole
team behind Sam seian and Jeffrey Shong
they're playing decent chess both of
them on plus one uh but R Fang Lee is
just simply struggling well and also we
had John Michael Burke which turned a
completely winning position in round one
against Arian Chopra into a loss as he
was not only unable to convert a queen
up endgame but actually ended up
blundering the queen away and that's
something I have to be quite critical of
because at that point they're leading
the match to to1 and when you're leading
the match to to1 you have you just take
a draw because he was just playing that
end game forever it was the kind of end
game that you could play forever but you
have to be practical you have another
round in the day you know you want to
finish the game you want to make sure
your team wins the match and you have
some time to rest to prepare and go to
the next round there's no point of you
know keeping the coaches on The Edge
keeping like your all team on the edge
and taking this kind of risk and this is
what I was talking about when I said
there's lack of experience because you
know a more experienced player would
just look at the the team situation
realize they're winning just make the
draw and just call it a day and not
going for Adventures absolutely I have
to agree with you experience talking
there as well we can take a look at
what's going on early in the opening
here in the games uh we see Sam Sean
saying a very typical Spanish uh we've
already seen a marshall Gambit in this
tournament but we're not going to see
one today in this game specifically as
Andre cenko has played the more
classical move D6 first uh it this tries
to avoid the anti- marshals that start
after Castle A4 which lead to completely
different types of games aonian plays
this consistently with the black pieces
uh D6 is completely different kind of
scenario and he's going to be trying
this very early development with of the
bishop to B7 which has become very
popular I would say in the last four to
five years before that it was almost
unheard of uh it had been seen in the
70s and discarded quickly but but this
idea of playing D4 and either playing uh
Rook E8 or Knight D7 quite early has
picked up some steam uh the idea is to
just completely solidify the position
here on E5 not being forced how to take
on D4 anytime soon and rearrange the
pieces in a more practical manner than
the Brier in which you are forced to
play Knight ba8 Knight D7 very quickly
Black's basically saying I have more
useful things to do than rerouting my
knight well in the Brier you're not forc
right it's basically you're admitting
your knight on C6 is not good not and
then you want to put it on D7 where it's
more flexible and it's not in the way of
your Bishops actually there's more
Harmony in your position yeah uh so here
Sean chooses the move D5 I have to say
I'm not fully familiar with this opening
but the ideas of the realz is something
that every grandmas is familiar with uh
night B8 and it boils down to a couple
of things first of all white has more
space but black has good defensive and
counterattacking chances black is very
quickly going to play a move C6 as he
cannot allow white to just retain the
space for free in the center if he does
White's just going to be better when he
plays C6 that's a different issue uh he
has to be very careful of the opening of
this bishop on the uh diagonal which of
course will be targeting F7 something
that I'm not worried about in a lot of
uh variations in this specific variation
with the Rook on E8 I always have to be
very careful that uh this opening on C6
actually works so going be like a nidor
type structure after you play C6 so it's
not really going to be so much of a
Spanish rather than nidorf and we are
talking about this a lot about the
richness of transformation of structures
in the Sicilian and in the realz because
imagine that this Pawn on C7 and this
Pawn on D5 simply disappear let's not
worry about the how or the when let's
just imagine that they disappear
suddenly the structure is a sicilian and
the concepts of the Sicilian structure
start shining through and the players
are just bull blitzing out their moves
just by well they're young players we're
expecting them to be very theoretical
especially Sam saan unlike ruing Lee
ruing Le is not very theortical no this
is they're the follow opposites look at
this guy's Go I mean they they could not
play any faster they way more time that
they started with somebody tell them
it's not bullet chest this is just
classical they don't want to play they
heard what you were saying you don't
want to play an increment so they want
to get as much time as possible on the
clock okay but uh this is something we
can expect from in this kind of
tournament where people if the players
become prepared knowing who they're
playing and such excellent coaching I
mean one of your coaches aruman is
coaching the world uh the the USA team
as well as well as the a player that got
second place in the US Championship this
year alach of Texas Tech University also
yeah my my rival in that sense coach of
Texas Tech University we we have some
great coaches here and um we do see in
this preparation that the players come
very well prepared well but this is
actually 20 moves of chest that they've
just played they've just blitzed out
this is the best thing to do when you do
have a second time control because
you're getting closer to move 40 but so
if you have like time trouble addiction
this is I'm a little bit worried because
usually in these positions if uh black
actually knows what he's doing then he's
going to fa quite well and I I love that
when you know that you've made a
novelty because they've been blitzing
out 20 moves black knows he makes a
novelty he makes it on the board stands
up and leaves immed
knowing that his opponent is going to
think and I know Sam Sean for a fact
he's quite an easy player to prepare
against he plays all the time the same
things I had the same experience against
him I was playing white in a very
important uh game in Chicago and uh I
did prepare like 20 something moves of
theory got a completely winning position
and uh just executed him afterwards but
in h this case black is trying to make a
draw he does have the bishop a he does
have the worst structure uh because of
the Pawn on D6 but I think he's very
very close to achieving equality but we
do have a very very important game on
our hands uh one that promises to be
very very explosive this game between
Chopra and Ru fangle and this is
probably going to be one of Tat's
favorites because we do have a sicilian
this is going to be explosive after
Knight B7 this is a chevening sicilian
and white can uh choose two plans he can
either go castle and after Queen to A5
he has to go B3 Bishop to B7 A3 this is
a very topical line but very complicated
Queen C7 uh a takes before D5 the game
simply explodes white has an extra Pawn
but uh the center gets wi open the
bishop on f8 uh becomes the PowerHouse
very very complicated and this is uh the
style of ruy fang instead of that white
played the move C4 very enterprising
idea now I'm threatening to play B3
perhaps A3 then Retreat my knight on C3
and simply just have full control over
the center after B takes C3 Knight takes
E3 Bishop B7 I think we had a few more
moves on the position Bishop E2 Bishop
B7 I expect short Castle not long Castle
because now uh the C file is open and
the king would feel a little bit unsafe
there but black is having a perfectly
fine position and I think uh he's
winning the opening battle on this one
if I remember my line or my games I
would say that I've played this with
Bishop C4 I think Bishop C4 instead of
C4 is a move because if absolutely
absolutely yeah in the chingan you don't
get the chance to develop Bishop so I
want to say I played this game in the US
Championship this year but Bishop C4
is as well I think C4 is actually the
main line yeah it has been played the
most times I I have seen this line
before C4 uh T takes Bishop B7 and this
despite being a normal Sicilian the fact
that you've already traded the B and C
pawns changes the dynamic quite quite
heavily for one thing uh the expansion
on the queen side which is something
white normally can never do because you
have this awkward Knight on C3 in the
way of your pawns uh is not actually
very feasible you can throw the pawns
forward on the queen side while actually
the normal plan of throwing your pawns
forward on the king side is kind of
silly if you play G4 and H4 and all
these kind of moves in this kind of
position the center's already a little
bit more open the queen side's a little
bit more open and your king is just way
more exposed you cannot push pawns on
both sides of the board you kind of have
to commit to one side you're only going
to have to play for the weakness on A6
and potentially uh the expansion of the
queen of the pawns on the queen side try
to create a pass pawn and have a better
end game but the problem is D5 is coming
really fast yeah that was my thought
like how do you stop D5 in this position
yeah well it's a good question I don't
because it's yeah I mean unless you have
Bishop I I think you have some ideas of
uh maybe taking exchanging the knights
on D5 and then with the bishop on D5
perhaps try a move such as Knight F5
some enterprising IDE such as that one
to try to get the bishop another idea
that I like Christian might be
immediately taking advantage of the
specifics of the position and we talked
this a lot about how there are general
concepts but also the specifics of the
position in this case the move Rook C1
really appeals to me because oh I see
why if you put the Rook on C8 just to
match my Rook the move D5 will always be
more difficult to execute this bishop on
E2 is already attacking A6 which which
means that after the massive trade on D5
nobody's going to be defending the pawn
on A6 if you play D5
immediately then after taking on D5
taking on D5 taking on D5 taking on D5 I
have the idea of playing Knight C6 at
the end this is precisely why I put my
Rook on C1 because now the Knight on C6
is defended and I'm winning the bishop
there well actually they played castle
castle so they both castled your idea is
actually very very intuitive but if you
include castles for now you have the
extra option of actually playing the
move Rook F to C1 and perhaps keeping
this Rook on A1 for uh the uh future
expansion on the queen side A4 B4
creating the pass Pawn as you were
mentioning take take and also
potentially you have the move Knight C6
yeah and uh white white would be better
if he manages to get the bishop there
either Bishop then I'm going to have a
perfectly P fine position if I grab your
dark Square Bishop your light Square
Bishop is quite blocked on this dangle
and only the long diagonal because of
Pawn on F3 no Bishop F3 would a terrible
move um but overall this is just a much
much better position for black black
needs to prepare that move D5 perhaps
with a move such as um Queen to B8 I saw
it playing while I was uh doing some
research rook fc8 and then only after
that play the move D5 but this is going
to be an interesting middle game battle
is going to be a battle between uh
strategic plans yeah actually and I like
that R Fang comes very well prepared you
can see it on the amount of time that he
has currently in the position way way
ahead of time on of his opponent already
uh he hasn't been blitzing out the same
speed that Sean has been but it's still
playing very quickly and very
confidently you must admit you you must
assume that rang here is well inside
preparation yeah probably one of his
coaches told him that playing E6 G6 is
not a good
idea just letting your opponent go H4 H5
and just uh Destro your position yeah
whatever happened yesterday could not
happen as we have here R bang Lee a 15
years old quite a young player uh
hailing from Plano Texas part of the
Dallas chess school and well he's not
the only player here also Jeffrey Shong
and him have been playing CH well
together forever and Christian and I
well we've been playing this young
player since they were kids I remember
we were actually discussing no we were
discussing when they were like 10 years
old and we were saying let's beat them
now while they're young because in two
three four years they're going to spank
us yeah I do have a plus score against
Jeffrey I have a plus 10 score against
ruang I've never played rang I have a
plus score against Jeffrey I even score
against him and I have a plus score
against kayen I remember I was shocked I
was playing uh Jeffrey Shong Friday
night after my classes at the University
and he was this little kid 10 years old
and uh he uh played the the Russian
defense and he equalized so easy he made
a draw so easy and he was 10 years old I
was a grandmas I was like wow you have a
bright future kid here we are here we
are oh speaking of Jeff J let's take a
look at his game and see what is going
on he is the top rated player in uh the
world as far as 16y olds are concerned
he's also the world junior Champion
Jeffrey Shong one of the top players in
the US one of the top players in the US
straight up probably next member of the
next Olympic team that's what
everybody's hoping he had a little bit
of a slump he's dropped down to 2642 up
from all the way up from 2670 that he
found himself only a couple months ago
and we're going to be playing a much
more sedate opening than the other two
players uh they're handling it much more
slowly this is a normal theoretical
Queen's Gambit declined Orthodox
variation you can see that a lot of
players here are not deciding to go for
the more traditional Bishop G5 which
allow allows the laser variation
considered to be almost equality Bishop
F4 is definitely taking isn't this
Leon's P line yes definitely
castles be aware of this yes of course
all the Armenians always follow Leon's
games here the move C5 is uh been played
many many times the idea of just
blocking out black pieces it's a good
time to play C5 as the there is no
direct way of destroying the pawn
structure uh the move Bishop B2 of
course also exists as well as some
others I I want to see what Jeffrey
chooses Bishop B2 is a little bit more
flat flexible but uh C5 has been
considered to be the more challenging
move for quite a while leads to very
close positions I think one of the more
famous games in this line was the only
time that Vish andan was able to defeat
Magnus Carlson in their world
championship matches and that was with
an excellent preparation specifically in
this variation must be nice to have a
memory and remember all this things um
but I'm I'm surprised why the players
are spending so much time in the opening
I wonder if anyone surprised anyone or
like what what going on cuz only six
moves and this is like a pretty
classical position it's not like
something has gone off I guess Marty
rosan doesn't play this regularly I'm
not very familiar with his repertoire as
far as Jeffrey who I am much more
familiar with as far as repertoire goes
he plays everything under the sun he can
wake up one day and just choose to play
D4 E4 Knight F3 the English whatever he
feels like very versatile player and I
think that at this point it's Jeffrey
that was unaware of his opponent playing
this variation specifically so he's just
choosing between all the lines that he
knows and that's sometimes a problem
when you have the opening and you know
four or five different variations and
you just sit there and you're like what
should I choose today why do I feel like
this is why I only play one thing
because I don't have this dilemma I just
play whatever I always play so I don't
have to sit there and worry about and
try to remember or make things up on the
go now this is also psychologically an
interesting position for Marte Roan he
is
uh not benched after this incredible
blunder that he had yesterday he has to
prove that he can play solid good chess
and he's doing it against one of the top
players in the world with the black
pieces it's not an easy task even when
you're psychologically in the strongest
of positions so I want to see how strong
he comes psychologically to this game
after yesterday's debacle yeah this is a
great taste test for them because this
is not an Olympia this is not world team
this is not European team Team
Championship you know this is I mean
they a lot of the players during the
interviews they said that this was very
important to me the team spirit of
course every time you're playing for a
team even if you're playing like amateur
team e or something it's like you feel
the pressure but it's a very good
experience to kind of understand this
Dynamic of the difference between just
playing your tournament and making the
quick draws that you're tired or you
know you feel like this is a good time
to make a draw and feeling the
responsibility that you're playing for a
team you cannot get a bad position out
of the opening you cannot just let your
opponent are prepar you cannot make a
dve with white easily you cannot not
take a drive and like you think you
might have chances but you need to take
a draw to win so you just have to make
the sacrifices for your team that's
something they need to start learning
and actually I think the world team is
doing a lot better at this than the US
team doing I have to agree it feels like
they're thinking about the other games
more than we are in uh like they're more
aware and I think they have a general
understanding of like how teams work I
think their dynamic in that sense is
better absolutely I have to agree
completely with that I also think in
Europe uh Team competitions are much
more prevalent than in the United States
uh they have leagues all over Europe
these players are preparing since a
young age to play in those League the
Bundesliga the French league very very
powerful uh competitions and they do get
that feeling the Russians uh have a huge
League even the Romanians have a great
League aleandro you are uh you are
invited to participate anytime you want
thank you
I don't like that
invitation I'll keep it in consideration
actually as Christian was after Queen to
G5 no I want to see this I was uh doing
some research and there are only two
games played uh by uh some 2400 Russian
players and in this position Queen takes
G5 H takes G5 was played both games
ended up in a draw I'm going to play A5
I'm going to challenge uh your queen
side structure play the move Rook to e
to C8 I'm going to keep this bishop
defending the pawn on D6 because that is
my only problem but you have one problem
on C3 as well I'm going to play this A5
to challenge immediately and have the
option of opening up the a file at any
moment and uh it's just going to be a
battle of the weaknesses but the problem
is both players have two weaknesses uh
you have the pawn on D6 and the square
on D5 as black white has uh the pawn on
C3 and after A5 the option of black of
taking on B4 so it's very very balanced
and uh most probably it would end uh a
very very easy draw for black instead of
that I really like what Sam did he
played this move Queen F3 which is a
novelty by the way but it maintains
pieces on the board it maintains the
queen next to the Knight we're going to
see the action of the queen coupled with
the action of the Knight potentially uh
bring some problems around Black's King
I definitely definitely like his
approach he doesn't want to exchange the
Queens he wants to keep it as
complicated as possible and this is his
style he needs to get those uh those
active pieces and he needs to start
attacking the king black is going to
play A5 Rook e to C8 but this is going
to be a very very interesting
strategical battle and of course we have
to understand that the value of Peace
trade and I think this is something that
I was just thinking that if you take out
the lights for Bishop the position is
just so much better for for white
because you get the classical good night
versus the bad Bishop once I put a
knight on D5 or F5 I mean it's just over
basically yeah this bishop on f8 doesn't
have a bright future if black cannot
achieve the move here D5 so of course if
you trade light Square Bishops then the
position heavily favors white but also
we have to think when your opponent
offers a trade like Queen G5 what are
the pros and cons of trading queens and
this comes down to how exposed my
weaknesses are when I have a queen on
F3 it's not only just about the weakness
of D6 and D5 which of course Christian
was talking about but notice is that
with the queen on F3 and a bishop on B3
a new weakness arises the pawn on F7 can
now be targeted a pawn is only weak if
it can be targeted and currently I would
have two pieces that demand that your
opponent defends it somehow it doesn't
matter how you do it but you're are
going to have to have at least one piece
tie down to defending this Pawn this is
of course very important also this queen
on F3 as a multi-purpose piece defends
this weakness that uh Christian was
talking about while if you see the queen
on G5 it doesn't have a job that I'm
entirely sure and very often he's going
to try to chase that Queen with a move
such as Queen F4 def if you exchange the
queens that would be pretty bad because
the bishop on f8 after G6 Bishop G7
opening up uh the long diagonal you're
going to have huge problems uh defending
the pawn on C3 so uh Queen F4 is
definitely on uh ESS peno's radar right
because comes back to the trades here uh
the trade of the Queens would definitely
favor Black uh unfortunately for Sam I'm
not seeing a great way to keep the
Queens I think he might consider Queen
D3 even because you're always going to
put the bishop on B3 so I don't think
you're always going to put the bishop on
B maybe I can play like Rook E3 at some
point and start harassing you Rook E3
and swing The Rook over to the king side
and yeah I can see that this queen on F4
feels quite uncomfortable actually A5
was played okay A5 was played I expect
A3 to try to keep uh the tension A5 and
now you expect A3 to keep the tension
yes I I quite like that move now would
there be a big problem with the move
Bishop B3 immediately Queen F4 probably
Queen F4 yeah I think it's almost forced
to play Queen F4 I think you have to
move your queen to D3 I play my queen to
D3 but I was already quite comfortable I
didn't see why I had to play the move A3
immediately I I want to play Queen D3
and then put my Bishop on D5 right that
is the trade that I would really love go
back one move so if you go Bishop oh
sorry if somebody is Hing I wanted to
play A4 A4 right away and not allow
Bishop D5 cuz I want to take on Bishop
D5 so you're forced to take with a pawn
but I forgot my Pawn was hanging no
after Queen E3 I still have to give a
slight preference to White's position
I'm going to play Bishop D5 next move
it's not a huge Advantage here black has
many resources I can even start thinking
of Rook fc8 which precisely prevents my
idea of a bishop D5 because after taking
on D5 I never want to take with a pawn
uh leaving a lot of weaknesses and uh
canceling out my advantages I want to
take with a piece but of course if I
take with the queen now C3 is under
attack not not hanging but under attack
I'm not entirely sure how I'm going to
take it but still looks a little bit
scary on the counter Play No but I mean
I don't really want to allow this and
the problem with the queen eight a b
before in that position and C2 yeah
a looks Anno that is also quite annoying
cuz you cannot take my Rook on A8
because Queen takes F2 Queen takes G2 is
just Checkmate yeah and then you can see
how black pieces are very active A2 is
also a weakness yeah this is and what's
so annoying about the queen on F4 I
cannot play Knight E3 my ideal setup is
to play Knight E3 Bishop D5 and just
somehow force it to trade off that
bishop or at least and get the Knight
directly E5 and at least if you're not
going to exchange you have to put your
Bishop on D7 which is not going to be
targeting me so I rather do that so this
is kind of like a hybrid between Knight
or and sikov yeah little The Bishop's on
f8 and we have this battle for the D5
Square which doesn't happen a lot in ner
because black usually has better control
of it shows just how versatile the R
Lopez is it can translate into so many
structures so many uh different openings
and ideas is just a universal opening
yeah which is why it's recommended that
beginners play it so they can learn
different different structures and to
learn how where to put the pieces in
different kind of position as opposed to
when you're playing a sicilian and
they're very Sicilian also has this kind
of things but it's quite unique in that
sense cuz you because the sicilan you
have to make very um strange decisions
whereas this is more classical and
natural we have to see I'm was played
after Queen F3 because some is
thinking oh5 sorry yeah oh okay so
Bishop B3 hasn't been played uh so
there's one more game we haven't looked
at at all okay let's go there uh which I
forgot which game SAR versus CA I
believe yes yes cha so let's take a look
Alexi Sara he he been a solid player so
far against Nicholas chea who was on the
receiving end of the gift Yesterday by
Mart
um although he had also a pretty bad
loss against Aran Chopra and the French
oh yeah yes we're going to have a
chebanenko or A6 slav something that's
actually Fallen quite out of fashion but
still perfectly playable don't you play
this I do play this uh well when you
said not in fashion it was a big clue
for me because you don't really play
anything that's in fashion yeah right
we'll talk about this later and after
what what happens when you make true
statements uh Bishop F5 is what the line
that I play and it's the favorable uh
the favorite line of the Chinese players
um both wangu bujang XI all of these
Chinese players at the top level Play
Bishop F5 nb7 is considered to be the
old line and as far as I was concerned
it is this what you're playing no I play
Bishop F5 uh Knight bd7 is something
that hasn't been seen in in quite a
while Bishop F4 Knight H5 and there's
actually two ways of playing here for
white Bishop D2 which is what uh SAR
chose or uh simply the move E3 which
defends the bishop and gives up the
bishop pair but the pawn on F4 will do a
magnificent job of preventing the break
E5 and now black has to come up with
some sort of counterplay and once you
put all your pawns on a dark squares
you're not particularly attached to your
dark Square Bishop that's true so it's
actually the piece that you want to give
away here after Bishop D2 Knight H F6
black uh White could go Bishop F4 and
for a draw but of course uh with a team
tournament situation and being a higher
rated player white has no interest in
this plays Queen C2 and I am must say I
am not terribly familiar with this queen
C2 ideas I have played this exact
position
before uh but with the pawn already on
H6 uh the way that happened was uh I was
playing a leonov and he played H H6
Bishop uh D2 and Knight F6 and then we
got to this position and it turned out
H6 was actually a good move for black
why uh at the end of the day actually G5
can be an interesting idea uh I forgot
exactly how that game went Al I
remembers that I somehow won a nice a
nice
variation uh but okay that was a very
long time ago uh literally was this line
in fashion back then it was then 2004
this was all the rage everybody was
playing this uh Knight H F6 Queen C2 G6
makes a lot of sense uh with the move
Queen C2 wh's IND getting a very uh soon
E4 but E4 it's quite committ it's very
committal you have to be very careful
about uh this kind of variations because
if you get something like this and I'm
able to play the move Bishop E6 and then
stick a bishop on
D5 yes white has a little bit more space
but black has an excellent excellent uh
Square on D5 pressure over the D4 pawn
and just about enough space to maneuver
all his pieces sometimes if the bishop
on E on on the light squares is blocked
in like with a move like E6 this can be
justified but with the bishop already on
E6 it's actually black that's taking
over the initiative so this has to be
done with a lot of care after the move
G3 uh White is uh playing a little bit
slower but you can see still playing
over the center he still wants to get
this E4 move in at some point and Czech
decides hey you're wasting too much time
I'm going to Counterattack on the other
side of the board B6 a logical break in
this kind of positions since after B4
and A5 he's trying to take advantage of
the fact that this Rook is uh on D1 and
on on A1 now what black has to be very
very very careful in this kind of
scenarios is very tactical Solutions
here right yeah is exactly the Tactical
solution of B5 does B5 work usually I
want to be able to just take the pawn
and liquidate the queen side but taking
on B5 here looks like it's almost losing
if I play C5 and then I can capture on
B5 with the Knight no I think after B5
you need to um you need to play Bishop
B7 actually can I take yeah this is the
TAC no I don't want to take on C5
because you have a rook on D1 so I don't
want that opening up but I think this
might work let's see taking on C5 taking
on C6 Knight B8 is almost forced I might
lose my D5 Pawn but details No actually
that's very important yeah you take and
then I think you have Bishop G5 which
looks very Bishop G5 and yeah it's
actually ready for this and iow you this
yeah you might wonder sometimes you look
at positions like this Rook E8 and you
see these two pawns on D4 and D5 as an
amateur a lot of players would look at
this and they would never play Rook a D1
because why would you there's a bishop
on D2 Pawn on D4 on D5 but you know the
plans and as an experienced Grand Master
you just know more or less where the
ball's going to be rolling and you know
that at some point the center is going
to break open or Black's going to
suffocate so you're ready for this uh
kind of breakthroughs and look at this
variation we were looking at in which
actually The Rook on uh D1 ends up being
perfectly placed pinning this Pawn on D5
getting ready to play the move E4 and
this looks like a huge Advantage for the
white side as I can't actually see how
you defend the pawn properly if E6 I
think E4 is just a double thread that's
extremely annoying and Rook D1 is the
kind of move that is very hard to
explain to amateur players because this
is something you tell players not to do
not to put the Rook behind the pawn and
on a close file and then all of a sudden
oh this is the one of the main ideas and
that's one of the tough parts of Chess
that we have all these general rules but
then there are the specifics of the
position that you completely have to
break those rules and it's kind of hard
to explain why or how well in this
position with did a specific line but
sometimes it's just hard to explain why
a piece belongs where it belongs and I
think uh one of the most important games
actually in this type of structure I
remember a game between Anand and Magnus
Carlson from the world champion ship uh
in 2014 I believe when Anand actually
played this break with B5 and even the
world champion wasn't ready um yeah they
went into like a deep deep theoretical
uh option in which the novelty came at
move 25 and and completely demolished
Carlson the only game that he won in
that match and uh you can see how
dangerous these these breaks are and a
very very key difference in that game I
think the pawn was on E6 and the bishop
was on E7 yeah this Bishop was over here
and the bishop on G7 I think is a little
bit worse place because with the pawn on
E6 and the bishop on G7 you leave the uh
key Square D6 uh un available for
potentially a white knight maybe Knight
B5 Knight D6 uh so um I definitely
prefer white and A5 was played so now
it's White's turn to think fp5 so let's
actually try to figure this out because
when you play we have an engine so if we
don't figure it out you let's come back
to that but I wanted to play Bishop B7
here and I was wondering if that works
Bishop B7 I am a little bit scared of
the move Knight E5 immediately this is
what I have to calculate as a as a
player with this kind of structures
because after Knight E5 again taking on
B5 just loses to C6 this is a simple
double attack I'm going to be uh double
attacking your knight and your rook in
this
variation can even take on E5 there
actually I can even take do that so that
does just flat out doesn't work uh the
taking here on C5 looks worse than the
previous variation so maybe just Rook C8
I don't want to give up my Bishop but r
c I think loses this Pawn because I take
with what actually doesn't really matter
what I take with oh and you just take
and I just take on D5 because this
bishop has been Unleashed yeah I don't
want to allow that so let's figure out
what to do after B5 now my guess is this
is what uh ccha was calculating in this
position after the move B5 I think he's
going to take on B5 and after this scary
looking move uh C6 Knight goes to B8 now
if you take on B5 Knight E5 is the best
move if you take on B5 I have this uh
tricky little continuation Knight takes
C6 Queen takes C6 uh Bishop to D7 I
regain my piece I have a pawn up I'm
going to solidify my Bishop on C4 uh B5
and that's just completely winning for
black so I believe this is what uh his
uh he calculated he decided to play A5
allow this move B5 but the problem is
after uh C6 after C takes B5 I can just
simply take Knight takes B5 I'm
maintaining this threat of playing C6 C7
now potentially okay you're going to
take take I always have the option of
solidifying this Knight with A4 in case
you attack it with Bishop A6 you
definitely don't want don't want to take
on B5 allow my Pawn from a uh file go to
the B file connect these two passers and
that would be just game over for black
uh but this position is very very
unpleasant nonetheless yeah I agree that
looks very uncomfortable to allow this
pass Pawn on 5 without uh your
development completely finished I have
to agree that this line that Christian
is mentioning looks so uncomfortable
this is the current position on the
board as Alexi sarana from Russia is
thinking about what to play in this
position the B5 move is obvious to every
single player uh pass a certain strength
but the calculation of it can be a
little bit tricky I like this trap that
uh Czech has put together but perhaps
you see a nice trap and you think oh
this this is a nice variation but you
don't calculate the Alternatives
properly and I think that this is what
is happening to check at the moment and
uh guys I think you might want to jump
to the game between Jeffrey Shong and
Marty rosion because we have a very
similar structure in the position wow
this is exactly what I was talking about
so why didn't he go B5 well the king's
in the center I'm assuming that's one
thing this is actually an unknown
theoretical line and this actually has
more immediate and tactical resources
than the other one so this is the ionian
variation basically of the Queen's
Gambit and after A5 which is if I
remember correctly this is the game
between Magnus Carlson and vishan Magnus
Carlson with black I actually don't
remember the bishop was on D3 or E2 and
I don't remember if it matters because
it might transpose back to each other uh
the problem with B5 at this position if
I remember correctly was that after Pawn
takes
C5 it was it pawn takes C5 I no no no I
can just take on B5 in this position and
you cannot play C6 because of Bishop B4
and and because precisely the in the
center uh there is no Advantage here for
the white side it's going to be why
isn't there an advantage because I
always have enough pressure here against
your pieces to start forcing some
simplification I think here I play
Knight E4 my memory is not what it used
to be but I think that I take take
another I've given F6 to my other Knight
can I take one D7 you can take on D7 but
again I see okay it's uh kind of pretty
right yeah
take
you take here you take with the Rook
everything hangs and who's going to
defend this
guy not me no actually uh black ends up
winning this position the move A3 is
considered to be forced by Theory uh and
this is precisely What Jeffrey has
played uh the move B5 will come at a
later date uh it depends exactly on the
specifics of the position uh the reason
that I was saying that Bishop D3 and
Bishop E2 transposing into each others
because normally black plays Bishop A6
getting rid of this horrible Bishop that
stuck behind the pawn chain um Bishop A6
Bishop takes A6 I've seen this position
so Queen E2 Queen E2 and then we've seen
this many times in in in the recent past
uh I don't remember but I I thought that
this was very close to equality it is it
is very close to equality according to
uh the theory the novel Theory but
nevertheless black is going to have a uh
struggle uh to to completely fully
equalize in this position because white
is still maintaining that nice space
Advantage he's going to go uh short
Castle then potentially transfer his
knights around maybe Knight E1 Knight D3
uh very powerful Defender and uh I think
he's just it's just going to be a long
game Jeffrey has definite chances of out
playing his opponent yeah this is games
tend to be incredibly long with black
even sometimes controlling the entire a
file putting a queen on A8 a queen on A7
putting a rook on A8 eventually taking
on B4 and white just going so what I put
put a knight on
C2 yeah and they just close the F KN on
C3 and you cannot actually penetrate
down the file and then I just play on
the other side of the board very
interesting strategical ideas speaking
of strategical ideas the game between
San and andreaen is going exactly so
good at this we're exactly down the line
that we predicted uh the move Bishop B3
to me was the most obvious we said Queen
F4 is basically the best move for black
because you do want to have this trade
of Queens it's kind of like a Tempo move
almost right it is a Tempo move exactly
and white is the one that does not want
to trade plays the move Queen D3 and now
uh as Peno is the one that has to figure
out exactly how he wants to deal with
the position uh he has obviously a
couple of ways uh the move taking on B4
always gets rid of the weakness for
white of the Pawn on C3 on the other
hand it takes a pawn away from the
center so in many cases if I play D5 or
something along those lines Block's
going to be able to be better imagine
that this bishop now lands on D4 it's a
long ways away but you can see this very
I don't think I can imagine that just
yet but it it could happen you know in
some kind of end game in some kind of
positions you weaken the D4 Square for
the bishop yeah that's the dynamic of
the position like sometimes you don't
really want to release the tension right
you just want to keep it there and but
downside here is you cannot really use
your Rook because I might just take on
A5 and then if you have to waste time
playing like Rook pack and take yeah
that's a lot of time and as you were
mentioning man would white love to play
the move 93 in the very next move and
just play 93 95 or even 93 Bishop D5 but
I can play Maybe G3 and then Knight A3
ah maybe G3 is in the works here for
white maybe G3 is a strategical threat
because G3 the queen actually doesn't
have any really good I have to go to F6
probably right you have to go to F6 or
G5 but I don't think it matters and then
play the move Knight E3 now that E4 is
not under attack put my pieces on the
live Square I I think you mentioned a
key word in this position and that is
dynamic white is playing for strategical
Trump uh black needs to find the dynamic
in the position and actually the best
way to do that is to take on B4 and play
the move D5 immediately uh control the
center e takes D5 Bishop to D7 A3 okay
you are a pawn up but I'm going to play
simply this move Bishop D6 I'm
controlling all the important squares
this bishop on B3 is just simply
attacking his own Pawn the pawn on A3 is
always going to be a weakness now I have
if you move this Knight I'm going to
play this E4 Queen takes Queen H2 uh the
Bishops are experiencing a lot a lot of
activity potentially F5 E4 Bishop to E5
uh very pleasant position a lot of
compensation for the pawn and if you
take with the bishop on D5 I'm simply
going to take Queen takes D5 Bishop
takes B4 I think uh human will go for
this type of position instead of e takes
D5 so if a takes B4 C takes B4 D5 is
going to come on the board uh I think
Sam is going to take with the bishop
after Bishop before before okay mve such
as Rook E3 uh this looks very very close
uh to equality and uh this is something
we were talking about during us Juniors
when we're doing comment is uh when you
have the worst position or well we can't
really call this position worse but
after G3 93 maybe mhm and kind of like
knowing that um exact moment when to
complicate the position and not
suffering it's like choosing whether you
should go for the Dynamics or accept the
worst position and just try to defend it
and try to
um you know just put the pressure on
your opponent to win and then you suffer
through it and then you make the draw
but that moment of like making the
correct decision is actually very
critical so perhaps this is already a
critical moment in the game where a
black must choose correct path otherwise
after d393 just looks quite nice for
white at least to me I got to say it's a
quality move this idea that Christian is
is is telling me about takes on before
takes and before D5 it's a quality move
this is a grandmas M move I mean you see
lower rated players they don't even
consider giving up a pawn with a Tempo
it's that mental block that you get that
you give up material with Tempe and you
say well I don't really want to do that
it's understandable too it's not like D5
is such a natural move here right very
counterintuitive White's on everything
to prevent it but then you analyze the
specifics of the position and I I really
love the placement of the Bishops Bishop
on D7 and this bishop on effect that
it's just dead it's just dead before you
push uh D6 now has life Bishop is going
to come to D6 it threatens things on H2
uh G3 is no longer something I want to
play because H3 is going to be very weak
thanks to the other Bishop this
structure on the queen said I have to
play A3 to retain my Pawn is now Under
Fire this Rook on A8 has suddenly gained
a huge amount of activity because in
this position after I take on B4 take on
B4 this Rook yes it's an open file but
now it's hitting a pawn that's easily
defended by an opponent Bishop whereas
in this case when the Pawn's on A3 Now
The Rook on A1 is completely stuck
defending this uh really bad Pawn on A3
what I really like about this position
that black has accomplished is he forced
white to put a Pawn on D5 which took
care of so many things a there is no D6
weakness well it's gone B your Bishop on
B3 is just bad and your knight can no
longer land on D5 so in just one one
move or one idea you basically just kill
your opponent's play and now the Knight
on F1 actually doesn't really have a
good square if I can land it on e4 and
then somehow go to C5 but that kind of
seems like a long ways away no this is
such a critical moment uh in this game
in this whole match because uh if as
Peno manages to find this idea of a Tak
be C takes before D5 uh then uh the
world is going to have a very very
positive outlook on this round but um
one thing I always tell my students if
you go deep into the opening go as deep
as possible into the middle game as well
with a computer assistant of course with
your own brain try to use your own brain
as well uh but definitely try to
understand the ideas and he did know the
move Queen F4 obviously he did know that
he has to chase the queen he should know
this idea of a takes B4 C takes B4 D5 he
should know why white should play the
move A3 instantaneously and uh we'll see
and he took he took on B4 instantly
savian is going to take on B4 no choice
on that and let's see if aseno shows
that maturity and that knowledge of
being able to sacrifice a pawn here with
the move D5 it's not we're not saying
the black's going to be clearly better
or anything but this is the only way to
solve his problems if he doesn't play D5
you can immediately as as a strong
player you can smell how bad Black's
position can become in only a couple of
uh moves here black plays a couple of
random passive moves and he's going to
be much much worse if not completely
lost you can look at G3 Knight E3 Bishop
D5 that's three moves and Black's just
lost yeah I mean you have you have to
have a good sense of the positions
because if you give this position
position to more amateur player less
experienced players like they may not
think this is a critical position you
know you want to put it like maybe
something like Rook C8 bring my Rooks in
the center I'm pretty sure anyone like
1600 1700 like yeah it's like of course
I want to put my my Rook on8 is not
doing anything so I'm going to move to C
which is of course going to kill any D5
ideas in the future because that's one
Defender uh did did he play D5 yet or no
uh I don't think Sam has actually played
before so I'm not sure why he's thinking
because he might throw in the move G3
but uh don't think that actually makes
his position any no I think that's going
to makes it worse because after D5 e
Bishop D7 H3 hanging if if I then you're
going to take with the bishop on D5
right now if I go completely crazy right
and if I go
G3 we already doing that Queen F6 and
just sacrifice the pawn with Knight but
here does Queen F3 I think that's what I
don't like about or if I take on C3 I
was going to play Bishop D5 look at the
Strategic interesting sacrificing PA
Rook C8 yeah this which one Rook F to C8
D to
C8 you cannot take on C3 so that's a
little bit of a problem no this is a
little too Fantastical uh yeah which
means the pawn of C3 has to be captured
but G3 I don't think is a plus for white
not such a strong move uh because we
were looking at all these variations
where H3 is just hanging right but even
after G3 Queen F6 like knight3 IDs I see
this queen F3 move which looks really
annoying uh Queen F3 and your attacking
this yeah so even this is not so even
this is bad so that means that G3 is
probably not a move that black white
really wants to play if you don't have
Knight E3 immediate followup uh which
means Sam should probably take on B4 in
this position yeah I'm sure he's going
to take and the question is whether not
his opponent's going to play D5 yeah but
let's take a look at another game while
they figure this out uh we we had that
Sicilian oh yes between rley I want to
check this outley yes and um wow we see
a lot of changes so if fact was played
yeah it seems like black solved most of
his problems let me take a look at as
we're looking at the Arian choer against
reang Lee game uh we left it off just
about here castles and he did play the
move that we were considering Rook ac1 I
did like Christian's idea of putting the
other Rook to C1 I liked uh keeping one
of the Rooks on the Queen's side but
okay Queen B8 was exactly what Christian
was recommending this queen is very
versatile here as the after a move like
D5 it's eyeing the dark squares on the
king side it's eyeing the weakness on B2
and it's allowing me to transfer the
Rook to C8 it's a very flexible move
very very flexible
A3 okay here A3 I quite understand
because you want to put the pawn on B4
and that kills a little bit this night
on D7 which would love to go to C5 in
many variations Rook d8 prepares D5 I'm
assuming x-ray against the Queen B he
has to play B5 because if white manages
to solidify uh that score on D5 play
Maybe Queen to A2 Rook fd1 Bishop to C4
Bishop to B3 uh not allowing you to
break with D5 then I'm just simply going
to uh start pushing my pawns on the
queen side and I'm going to have a clear
Advantage because you get you get
smothered you have to play D5 at some
point and this seems a good point to do
it uh he took on D5 takes on D5 with the
Knight and uh well considering that this
bishop on E3 is hanging I don't see a
great alternative to taking the Knight I
mean this position looks so nice for
black uh well you can take can you
cannot take and go Knight C6 anymore
because Knight that's a very important
point and this explains why you have a
rook on d8 we were talking about earlier
the ideas of going Knight C6 and winning
one of the Bishops but tactically this
is refuted by putting the Rook on d8 as
after taking on uh C6 taking on C6 and
Knight E5 uh I'm attacking this KN this
queen and the knight's attacking the
rook and you can't coordinate them to
defend uh properly so black just emerges
of the exchange instead uh here white
has to come up with something a little
bit more clever promise I don't see much
yeah I mean just I'm going to put a
queen on B7 my knight on B6 probably
Rook C8 and you cannot really do
anything to my A6 Pawn which is the only
weakness I mean your main idea is going
to be Knight B3 Knight A5 but it's
nothing special I have to say that white
Black's not better I we're I'm not going
to go ahead and claim that but I don't
think he's worse either he about equal
because D5 is like Black's dream in the
Sicilian that's like the whole point
almost of the whole Sicilian right if
you can play in D5 exchange the E4 Pawn
with D6 Pawn without um anything
terrible happening to your position like
it's usually pretty good yeah that means
black has solved all of his problems so
and I think this is the case here I
don't I don't see any problems here for
R Fang uh much better opening than he
had yesterday with the black pieces and
he's doing great I think he's doing just
fine in the Sicilian no I agree there I
don't see any problems for him but one
game in which uh the United States is
not doing that well is this game between
San and Czech and as you guys were
mentioning after B5 uh I was expecting C
takes B5 and that trick after C6 Knight
B8 Knight takes B5 Knight to C6 that I
just showed earlier Bishop B7 was played
but after Knight E5 this position
becomes almost unplayable because after
Knight E5 which is probably forced uh D
takes D takes E5 Knight to D7 I have so
many ways of building an advantage the
simplest one is just taking on C6 Bishop
takes C6 exchange the Bishops Bishop
takes D5 and now after Bishop takes D5
Knight takes D5 you have plenty of
options of recapturing the pawn but
unfortunately we're going to look at the
difference between the pieces after that
this Knight on D5 is a complete monster
if you take on C5 with the Knight I'm
simply going to defend with I'm simply
going to defend my Pawn on E5 or perhaps
even keep the Dynamics in the position
and play the move Bishop to G5 threaten
uh the move Knight H C7 now you have
huge problems defending that pawn on uh
E7 we see the difference between the
pieces the bishop on G7 is not playing a
major role the Knight on C5 looks nice
but it's not really doing much it has a
nice Outpost but you always need to look
for purpose in your pieces the Knight on
D5 is a huge huge piece the bishop on G5
very active The Rook on D1 even
potentially I will be able to move it
back to B1 and attack your weakness on
B6 this is just a very ugly position for
black and I'm not really sure how Czech
has any way of actually counteracting uh
this easy plan for white no I doesn't
look very happy either and Bishop B7 was
actually my move but then you suggested
95 I believe yeah we were actually
looking at the specific variations and
it looked uh I think CH is realizing as
Kisa
y as karisa Yip explained about his her
position yesterday looks sketchy after
95 I just don't like Black's position it
doesn't feel like he can solve his
problems he needs a nice tactical
solution to everything but because of
the placement of some of the pieces
specifically this Rook on D1 is super
annoying in every variation in which uh
this Pawn on D4 disappears of the file
either because he captures a knight on
E5 or Pawn on C5 in all of these
variations it just feels like black
doesn't have enough to equalize and if
you don't equalize in this
position you are okay prediction really
really it's going to be really difficult
prediction for the score for today's
round now that we're maybe quarter way
in the
round I say uh two
I think uh optimistic San is going to
win for the world team Ru Fang is going
to bounce back and score for uh the
American
team savian is going to make a draw and
uh I think Jeffrey is not going to be
able to break Marty rosian and that's
going to be a 22 that's my
prediction oh what about you
guys oh I think us team is going to lose
again oh no no
that's not a good prediction well I
think let's see who what's going to
happen um what is the game Rel so I
think nich Nicholas I don't like saying
this I don't like saying someone's going
to lose Nicholas is in trouble I think
Nicholas I think Nicholas is going to
lose and yes nich is going to lose I
mean this position is already very
difficult maybe Sam will also lose so I
think it'll be like two and a half to
one and a half Sam is going to lose wow
I mean he is position is it's an
interesting position I think maybe I
think s is going to hold the I'm not
going to say something but I think it's
pretty Universal to say that che's
position is so bad that it's kind of
hard to even optimistically say he's
going to try to hold so you don't think
Ru Fang is going to be able uh to take
advantage of the fact that he completely
equalized out of the opening no but my
boy my boy Jeffrey is going to pull
through come on the guy is not even done
with the opening it's a solid position
but he's a higher rated player he has
more experience I believe in him his
opponent just blundered what horribly
yesterday yesterday psychologically he's
done it's time for Jeffrey to take
advantage of this and play a good game
but Jeffrey completely butchered his end
game Advantage he had the winning Rook
end game yeah that was very strange
yesterday he played fast and then he
just missed a very very simple tactic
that just equalized the position
instantaneously and then he had to agree
we saw on his face that he was quite
disappointed we'll see if he manages
psychologically to bounce back today and
score a very very crucial Victory uh for
the juniors of the United States yeah
these kids are like 16 17 years old I
don't think they have like this heavy
burden that we do of years and years of
making mistakes and messing up positions
that not winning tournaments I think for
them bouncing back should be pretty easy
yeah like what problems do they have
well there's a lot of pressure on these
guys and let's remember I think alundra
that but I mean this is not a tournament
I think they have like a lot of pressure
now I do want to point out that uh the
and Alejandra you were mentioning
yesterday Jeffrey had a rough year he
has had a very rough year he's he's been
feeling the pressure uh this whole year
Sam seon is breathing uh on his neck uh
he's basically the same rating as him
right now he had a 100 points Advantage
last year I think at some point yeah I
was about 100 during the year so uh you
know it's difficult it's difficult I
mean okay I'm not like completely
serious when I said of course there's a
pressure of course they they're
professional players they're not just
kids they do feel this but um I I don't
think when when you're younger like you
don't really like you don't really have
this heavier burden right I think you
can balance SP a lot easier or maybe
it's a personality thing rather
than I think it's more of a personality
thing I have seen some kids get stressed
out I mean on every single game of chess
so it depends on their attitude it
depends on their coaching it depends a
lot on the pressure that's put in by
their parents by their coaches sometimes
even by the entire country that gives
them the support to be in in many many
different tournaments right they're like
the pride of the country and they're
being followed uh everywhere espe
especially in countries where chess is
such a big deal like in
Rica well back in the day that's true
yeah especially like I mean like I was
saying uh of course this is a serious
tournament but um especially like if
you're traveling from all the way from
Russia Oria you do want to feel the
pressure but at the same time this is
not like again not the Olympia or
anything so this is more like you want
to gain the experience and if you're
going to make mistakes this is a good
place to make your mistakes I could say
so but somebody that's not making any
mistakes so far today I really like the
um Mastery that this guy is showing us
Andre esipenko 15 years old excellent
understanding of the position has played
the move D5 that we were looking at I
really like this move you give up a pawn
with a Tempo you give your opponent a
pass pawn and still because of the
Dynamics of the position that we were
explaining earlier it's completely
sounding actually the best move in the
situation yeah I mean this is uh this is
a great move and I think maybe this took
took um just took s by surprise and uh
we're going to take a little break very
soon but before that we do have a
feature about uh world team coming to
the
US it's my first time here I've enjoyed
everything the hotel and the playing
Hall are excellent yeah this is my first
time in St Louis in fact my first time
in America uh it's quite a nice city
it's pretty big and the hotel is quite
nice it's my first time in the US and St
Louis I like it here very much the chess
club is so cool thanks to the organizers
for the great organization and the club
it's my first time in the US I like it
here very much it's very beautiful and
clean the chess club is great and it's
very obvious that chess is developing in
the US I saw the biggest chess piece the
king just opposite the road so yeah it
is nice nice feel yeah this is my first
time in the
CL uh it's nice to be here and many play
have been here Sky Pro so I'm happy to
[Music]
be a question on Twitter from
damass uh I should not have pronounced
that uh that was a bit of a trap
yeah for those of you who are new to
chess it might look like ba3 is an
illegal move here because white advances
point two squares not one but it's a
little something we
call and you can do that but you have to
do it instantly you can't wait for a
move like let's say play King E7 King G2
and now try because I could have do
it I'm sorry this is this is too funny
for words this is a software glitch I'm
pretty sure there's not a
lot Lawrence hello
Lawrence yeah I'll play four against
Lawrence and now he's going to play
something against me which we discussed
at length uh during the course of my
stay yeah he told me this is excellent
D5 this was what I was kind of hoping
for because now I think E5 is no
Lawrence this is not how chess
Works sadly would be much much more fun
if chess actually worked like this but I
don't think it does or maybe it
does well that's me retting what I just
said how did I get from there to here is
a little bit beyond
me and what's worse I will never hear
the end of
it my quality of life has just gone
downhill tremendously because I'm
actually sharing the office with the
[Music]
guy be surprised be intrigued be
delighted the World Chess Hall of Fame
in St Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chest
and ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and worldclass art play
together the World Chess Hall of Fame
mind art
experience
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
a
[Applause]
[Music]
he
welcome back everyone if you're just
joining us this is round five of the
Millennial Match tournament under 17th
section my name is Abrahim and I'm in
the studio with grand m Alejandro
Ramirez and we're bringing you all the
action from round five day three of this
tournament yeah already quite
interesting games that we have even
though it's only been an hour and suon
to the round as uh I'm really impressed
by this Russian player Andre aseno only
a feed Master 15 years old but he's
showing some excellent excellent talent
and I love the way that he's playing
today I don't know how you can be 25 23
and only be a f Master yeah I think it's
just the title hasn't CAU up to you
you're so strong and you're rating being
source so fast that the title is unable
to catch up with usually it's the other
way around the players chasing the title
but not in this case that ESS Peno will
surely be having The Grandmaster title
in his hands very very soon well it's
more interesting to be a 2500 rated FM
than a 2500 rated Jam I guess that's
true when everyone talks about it's like
why is this guy still in FM your J
strength let's remember the 2600 FM from
Russia has certain Vladimir karnik who
skipped entirely over his International
Master title and he became quite a good
player yeah and we have Andre yeno years
old already rated 2523 having a very
good tournament here so far yeah he
bounced back perfectly from his first
loss against Sean uh with two wins in a
row uh so so far so good here for the
young player yeah and uh today he's
having a very good game very impressive
he had a very impressive preparation he
found all the curricul moves after
because sometimes we see maybe not so
much at the higher level when the
players come prepare pred they know the
opening and then once they play the
opening they just don't know what to do
with the pieces and I think this is
something you see in like under 24 2300
level more often than in 2500 and up
trust me the 2500 sometimes I make a few
moves and I'm like what am I doing in
the middle game so it happens at all
levels but I mean it does happen at all
levels but I think there's a certain
level where if you survive the opening
no matter how good your opponent's
preparation is your opponent's going to
make a mistakes actually yesterday uh we
had an interview with BB Sara when she
said oh my opponent out prepared me but
then you know she started playing on her
own and uh she started making mistakes
which is understandable when you're not
very experienced you're young and you're
not very high rated this is the kind of
mistakes that happened and Sam Sam did
take the practical decision in my
opinion he did take with the bishop on
D5 I was mentioning this is a critical
moment you can take with the E Pawn or
you can take with the uh Bishop E Pawn
after Bishop D7 Bishop D6 uh F5 E4 as we
were mentioning the position becomes uh
wild then the two Bishops are going to
prosper uh in in that case Bishop takes
D5 is simply trying to limit uh Black's
options after Bishop takes D5 Queen
takes D5 Bishop takes B4 The Rook moves
uh probably almost anywhere in the
position not on B1 because you don't
want to get your uh Rook trapped but if
you go to E3 E2 the position is going to
be very very close to equality and I
think this is just going to pet out into
a draw and that's actually a very nice
success
opening wise here for ESO who uh I have
to say Sam S is an incredibly strong
player but this is the second time in a
row with the white pieces that he
obtains absolutely nothing uh the one
game that he played against saan where
he was just easily drawn in 17 moves I
mean in the team tournament that's a
little discouraging and right now if
you're a team member and you see this
position after Queen takes D5 which we
have on the board obviously Black's
going to retake him before what else is
he going to do
uh it doesn't seem like very high hopes
of winning he would somehow have to
trick his opponent and win the B5 Pawn
without losing the A2 Pawn to have
realistic winning chances but come on
that's not really going to happen you
you don't have rookie B1 because of
Bishop C3 and it's so important if you
can draw with black because you're
giving your team such a big Advantage
because they do have the two whites to
to work with yeah and they're in a
situation they uh like they have a big
Advantage actually because in the under
1400 under 1400 under 14 section uh they
are out raing us
yeah especially in the girl SE yeah I
mean a wonder is the highest rated
player in that section but besides that
uh the rest of the field is heavily
favored for the world team and another
psychological advantage the world team
has right now is the game of uh Nicholas
ccha against uh San and he's in big big
trouble and everybody knows it is very
very easy to see that white has a huge
Advantage all the players are swarming
around the board they know know who's on
top they know they're going to score
there and uh that just gets a little bit
weight off your shoulder if you're
playing in that team and uh that's why I
think the world has another
psychological advantage over the us at
this moment they they don't have to win
matches if like if they draw in under 17
they're good to go so the pressure is on
the US to win matches so in the under 14
I think they at Le I don't think the US
had a match where they're winning
yesterday they barely through we saved
matches miraculously almost I mean you
can see especially round one one at some
point I thought it was going to be 4-0 I
thought this is just so bad yeah I mean
you can see the strength of the players
around the world coming here to play
against some of our best but man are
they putting on the pressure and I agree
that the under 17 I thought that's where
we have them that's where we have
Jeffrey Shong World Junior Champion we
have Sam seian Continental Champion we
have so many strong players in that
section but look at what the world is
saying hey we also have our own
Superstars perhaps you haven't heard of
them just yet but you're going to be
hearing plenty of them in the years to
come especially the way that they're
playing they're being very very
impressive and as Christian was
mentioning there are some positions in
team tournaments when you look at the
board and you say wow that's a mess I
actually don't know what's happening I'm
going to trust you take it it's a mess
uh if you see the objective evolation of
the position perhaps your teammate is
lost you can't really figure it out in
this position with Nicholas CA you don't
have to be a grandm to know that this is
busted this position is completely lost
actually I already think the move E6
should be winning but even if that
didn't work a simple Retreat of the
bishop should be is blasting position so
over I get I get my medal yeah Christian
is here we get medals today I guess uh I
guess this is your first I will give you
a bronze medal for this one we'll get
we'll get the gold well I guess the best
move when I get a bronze medal the gold
medals towards the end okay so what
happens so after you after E6 the
position is just completely over I'm not
really sure what you're going to play
going to take your Pawn PA I'm going to
tell you all your pieces are hanging yes
H Bishop takes H6 Bish you cannot take
on D5 because after Queen takes G6 uh
you're going to get checkmated in the
next move in the exact next move if you
take on H6 Queen takes G6 you have to go
back but now I'm just simply going to
transfer my Knight Knight F4 I'm
threatening this move Knight H5 Queen
takes G7 Checkmate the bishop on C6 uh
is UN pre Queen takes E6 if you manage
somehow to defend all these other
threats like such as Knight C5 Knight
takes Knight H5 Knight takes E6 this
position is just uh completely hopeless
so let's look after Bishop takes H6 at
the move or let's look at after E6 at
the move H takes G5 let's say you let's
say you take the bait after e takes F7
King takes
F7 Knight takes B6 everything's hanging
everything is just simply hanging even
he takes D7 was surely winning I think
an important an important idea is that
after Bishop takes G2 I don't think you
can take because Queen takes B6 is
coming on the board and the Queen on C2
is under attack you cannot take on B6
because Rook takes C2 so after Bishop
takes G2 I think you have to see this
move Queen takes B3 okay then you're
going to go Rook takes D7 next move the
queen is actually trapped you're going
to lose your queen it's not it's not
hard ites F7 uh Queen B3 on in the
position is just a massacre on the board
this is not what you want to have no but
it's not even the only winning move I'm
sure that if I have a feeling I was
looking at chua's body language he knows
it look at him he should know it I mean
wow it's not and even though those are
very flashy variations I mean after the
move E6 that we were analyzing ponx uh G
G5 I mean yes I can start calculating
Point takes F7 but if I take on D7 it's
just kind of resign right and you're
going to lose a queen no Bishop do
so ah because of the trick of uh I was
going to take and fall for the same
trick even though that's probably also
losing because after no it's OPP quite
opposite color Bishop so wait that but I
have a Pawn on B7 so a this is almost
almost lost but I agree he takes F7 is
much much cleaner yeah but I mean he has
all the time in the world has the
positions just going to sit there and
figure it out while his opponent's going
to sit there and suffer we do expect him
to find the mov V6 but as I mentioned I
I would be surprised if it's the only
way to win the position okay let's find
another way uh you might earn a gold
medal today if you find another way to
you're not earning anything for this
one Bishop E3 mov moving the bishop back
Bishop B3 Bishop I mean Bishop B3 Bishop
F4 is a huge Advantage yeah definitely
not getting a gold medal forting gold
medal for that E6 is winning but you
know s is looking at E6 right now no
definitely you want you want to give
killing blow you we talked about this a
lot in the US junior Championship where
if you give your opponent more and more
chances you keep forgiving them on the I
mean you might get in trouble you might
give him hopes you might give them
positions in which you can actually
recover from we saw it in the US Junior
over and over and over again uh
positions where one side should just
finished their opponent off and they
didn't and let's see if Alexis s from
Russia here can find the killing blow E6
that just seals the deal does not allow
counterplay that is the game yeah but I
mean I don't see why he wouldn't find it
I mean maybe he miscalculate something
but definitely he's calculating E6 right
now 100% yeah and we're talking about in
US Juniors but here we have very
experienced players 2500 Grand Masters
and they're not going to give as many
opportunities somewhere like 2400 2300
and uh if you do give this opportunities
your opponents are not going to be as
forgiving like if you give your
advantage away that might just be it
yeah here we have Alex s Grand Master
From Russia 2510 I mean lower rated than
the F
Master yeah really that's true no but an
amazing player of course uh not only
just grandm strength already has his
title and he's been playing a solid
tournament here he drew Jeffrey
yesterday he drew Jeffrey he drew Sam uh
he's had a solid showing and now with
the white pieces he's showing his power
you were mentioning the importance with
the white pieces in A Team tournament uh
Sam has been unable to get anything with
the white pieces today K's played yeah I
do see E6 on the board6 on the board is
on the board E6 on the board I mean it's
just the quality of players that are
coming here to St Louis you can see it
E6 just does not forgive no a player
like this does not forgive and tactical
17 years old no excuse not to find
tactics like AB not forgiving of the
young players but no I mean E6 very
natural move you're like taking
advantage of this H6 move G6 Target like
everything is played perfectly and we're
say when you're looking for a final blow
and here it's just kind of it's it's
just like there you don't have to look
very hard it's pretty it's there it's
actually relatively simple to calculate
he's done it he's done the hard part so
the rest is going to be a relatively
easy conversion Czech I feel like Czech
just uh simply became rest Reckless
after yesterday's uh impressive win but
which came after a very very big blunder
from his opponent I'm not going to call
that impressive sorry it it still was
impressive I mean okay I you you win
against the leader of the world team in
20 25 moves uh you feel a burst of
energy but that can make you a little
bit Reckless and we see it in this game
he played the opening just uh very very
bad in my op I don't know how well it
translates but in Spanish we have a
saying that you didn't win a game your
opponent lost yeah and this is exactly
what happened yesterday I mean cha
didn't actually move a finger to win the
game yeah he just made moves and then
his opponent just collapsed he just
collapsed by himself and I think
recovering from your winds is very
important like that recovering from your
WS that's very good you have to get you
have to recover from your losses you
have to recover from your wins so you
don't want to be emotionally here you
don't want to be emotionally like there
you want to like be steady and even if
you're really hyped up from your um
winds it still messes up with your
emotional being and you don't want that
like you want to have the confidence you
want to feel like okay I'm playing well
I'm calculating well I don't need to uh
question myself I don't need to question
my calculation but you don't want to be
so hyped up that you think your
opponents are always going to give you
games and this is something actually
that happens to me sometimes after
really good game I'll play like one of
my worst games if I beat a grand master
my very next game can be just so
horrible I can lose so easily because I
do get this energy I think it happens to
a lot of us uh because uh yeah you're
simply feeling Invincible after you play
a great game uh you win against a very
strong opponent and then you start uh
thinking that anything is possible you
can play any move and you're going to
outplay your opponents but definitely
we're seeing today that's not the case
SAR came very well prepared he executed
the bre break with B5 Knight E5 followed
up by very precise play and right now
black is going to resign at any moment
and I think it's specifically dangerous
when this happens few times in a row
like when you have few easy games and
you think okay this is my tournament but
then every game is a challenge and every
game like even your lower rated opponent
can play a really phenomenal game so
nothing is really guaranteed so I think
this is a very dangerous Zone and I have
to say his uh loss was pretty bad that
French defense right he just got a bad
position opening yeah it was a very
strange decision where he traded queens
in a he a Noel to I think the kn6 I
hadn't seen I hadn't seen it either but
it seems that just out of the opening
Nicholas cheer wasn't able to continue
the the correct path he got lost in the
some complications that he created and
um he lost without too much of a fight I
think against Chopra and today against
uh
Sara also not much of a fight I mean
white played a couple of natural moves
black blasted open the position and only
for it to
uh Boomerang back on him so his all his
games seem very one-sided and actually
we see Ru Fang Ley and him both are kind
of not doing so well and they are coming
from the US junior Championship that
concluded like a week ago it's kind of
understandable and then they had a
training right after they even get to
rest I mean Kasparov was here I don't
think they were going to say oh sorry
Gary I'm taking the day off you know I'm
tired it's like no Kasparov is here
you're going to be training but I have I
have to agree with you that it doesn't
seem that they're pulling together in
this tournament too well uh our lowest
three boards in the under 17 they're not
doing great I mean John Michael Burke is
currently on minus two he lost this
unbelievable game in the first round
where he really really needed to pull
through and he lost yesterday a position
where he was just Superior against his
opponent against SE panko I believe and
uh yeah I remember that game but in that
game was a little bit different I think
it was very he made one Mist like he had
a critical point and he made one mistake
and he was just worse like at that
critic point he didn't figure out
whereas his first game I think is less
that one is um something his coaches had
to talk to him about and explain to him
like you don't do this you know you have
to develop a danger sense and actually
as we was talking about this we do have
moves in the game I think he's doing it
uh as they say the other way around I
don't I'm not sure why but after Pawn
takes G5 instead of taking first on F7
he's first taking on B6 perhaps
retaining the possibility of taking on
uh D7 with PA yeah if you take on G2 I
might just take the7 with a pawn and
yeah I could always transpose right I
could just take on F7 and transpose but
taking with the pawn I mean just every
piece of hanging so he probably has to
take on E6 I would guess but after
Bishop takes actually Bishop takes same
yeah because if I go here here I cannot
take with the Rook because again of the
trick but if I queen G oh no you have
Queen B8 yeah Queen G6 attacks The Rook
on E8 but after Queen B8 everything's
defended uh so I wonder what he has um
well you can at the worst case scenario
you stick with a knight and this hanging
F6 is hanging Knight E5 is hanging but
the other one seem more convincing I
think Queen G6 should be winning also
instead of Knight takes D7 just keep the
tension but it takes up S was more
convincing no or no no no absolutely
absolutely but this is just this is
Splat this is completely over well the
other one you're winning like Queen this
one I would be surprised I don't win
more of I I remember that game in US
Juniors when one of the players won a
queen and you were like so critical like
this is not good enough I don't want to
win an extra Queen why it was made on
the board you don't win a queen when you
have you have made on the board you just
don't do it you give your opponent
chances now you're making it sound like
he want a full Queen he want a queen for
a rook in a piece so it wasn't as
clearcut as you're making it sound the
engine actually uh after F takes C6 um
they just want to take on G6 first they
don't want to activate your Rook from C8
not
just take on G6 maintain all the threats
in the position the E6 Pawn is also
vulnerable because the Rook is not on
the six rank this is just game over
completely so what wondering maybe
Knight takes B6 could be an idea for
black but after e takes F7 you have to
play a move such as king to f8 if you uh
if you take here after Queen B3 this is
just simply game over on the spot uh you
do have to play the move King to f8 but
after Queen takes G6 you can imagine
this is not going to last for a long
time what is this position I'm looking
at just completely lost yeah and if he
takes Rook dead you're going to be like
no this is not good enough you think the
Rook is not good enough you got have
made him no but okay this is just uh
yeah this is just going to be a matter
of how not the like how is white going
to choose let's take a look at some of
the other games that perhaps let take a
look at Sam's game and see if we have uh
anything interesting not too much still
a couple of things to solve for aseno as
uh he does have to figure out a way to
defend the pawn on uh B5 I'm not
convinced and I have Rook F3 yeah and
you have things yeah have Rook F3 which
K kicks out the uh Queen from the
defense of F7 so you have to be I guess
a little bit careful in this position
still yeah let's try to figure out have
a double check so I I take back when I
said about Sam is going to lose but I do
still think that us is going to lose Z's
definitely not going to lose no I mean
he's a practical player he didn't just
play like it takes the five and go for
crazy complications
and again this is something that comes
with experience like you kind of look at
the position like yeah even if you don't
know the objective evaluation you're
just like no I don't want to deal with
this and you just go for something safer
right all right so how do I defend here
actually well there was a common tactic
in I think yesterday broadcast and that
was materialism and uh in this position
actually black has to just simply
sacrifice the pawn on B5 and try to
activate his pieces in the meantime he
has to play a move such as Bishop to f8
after Queen takes B5 I'm going to attack
uh this queen I'm going to open my files
for for my Rooks and then I'm this Pawn
on A2 is going to be uh permanently a
weakness I'm going to double up rook A4
Rook to A8 and uh according to the
computer um in my opinion also from a
human perspective I feel there's enough
compensation for equality if you try to
do something such as Rook e to B8 and
defend the pawn after Rook to B1 you're
starting to uh uh feel the pressure
because Bishop to f8 Rook takes B5 and
if you play Rook takes B5 Queen takes A8
now you don't have two Rooks on the
board you're not going to be able to
stop my a pawn from advaning because
you're not going to be able to create
that battery that double Rook battery on
the aile and it's going to be very very
difficult uh to deal with this pass Pawn
this could turn in Sam's favor for sure
wait I have a question after Bishop f8
can I go Rook F3 I think Rook E8 but
he's only going to give me like a silver
medal or something like that no but then
Queen B3
Queen to B3 Rook A3 I would assume I I
just think it's funny so I want to
activate my pieces and then play Bishop
f8 but I understand you want to keep
your king safe and connect the Rooks oh
so the whole idea is Rook A3 I'm always
going to attack your queen Rook takes F4
Rook takes B3 and I think if you take on
F7 I think I'm just going to maybe take
take and Rook D3 yeah I need to keep the
activity I need to keep the activity in
my pieces and also this Knight on F1 if
you don't manage to jump on E3 and you
don't for the moment because I'm simply
going to take your Pawn on B3 you have
to defend that guy but after Bishop C5
Knight E3 is not coming on the board
where are you going to put your knight
you cannot put it on G3 because Rook
takes G3 is coming um simply put my
pieces are much more active and that's
more than enough for compensation yeah
actually you can imagine black White's
almost in zong in that position yeah
black still has some problems to choose
but we saw he already took the dynamic
approach to solve the problem so we can
expect him to continue in the same
spirit I I like what Sam is doing yeah
he has an understanding of what to do
with this position so he understand that
this is about the Dynamics and not the
materialistic concept but in the
meantime we have a very special graphic
for um one of our members of our team uh
we do have a very special birthday uh we
want to wish happy birthday to Marcus
bat happy birthday happy birthday well
from all of us in the studio this guy
you you might not see him in front of
the camera but man he works hard he is
the reason one of the reasons that of
lights and oh yeah all of this works yes
there are a lot of people working in a
truck we do not see everything that goes
uh behind the scenes but so many people
working so hard to put the show together
and Marcus uh one of the key members of
the production team making sure that
everything runs smoothly and all the
players and all the production team is
comfortable and the viewers get the best
experience possible and they're going to
be joining us for the entire summer of
ch we're going to be here at the match
of the Millennials coming up the
singfield cup and the St Louis rapid and
Blitz so they're going to be here for a
while yeah so I might turn 35 by the
time all over yes that might be sure I
think some new moves have been played in
that game and uh for some reason s
didn't take my advice he did in this
position after F takes C6 he did take on
C6 first still this doesn't spoil the
advantage the position Black's position
is still completely hopeless after Rook
takes D6 Knight takes C7 Queen C7 Queen
takes G6 I just simply have um how many
pawns two pawns up your king is
completely unsafe and yeah I think this
is just uh almost resign well basically
I'm going to take on G5 as well no this
is just game over no it's completely
done I I didn't realize why it has extra
material I thought you're just playing
for I thought you're just playing for
the king and then I didn't realize
you're winning punts in the way so so
move 9 nice tactics a little tactic
there to finish off the game after Rook
takes D1 one I can even just take the
Rook because Queen takes E5 is not
playable as Rook d8 is immediate
Checkmate uh which means you have to
play something like I guess Rook takes
C5 which loses to pretty much every move
on the board Queen F7 Rook D7 so now
we're going to name every single move
went on the board no 95 is a nice
Finishing Touch and that's the that's
this is a good time to resign here for
chea I mean I think he's just going to
sit and suffer a little more at the
board and think about everything that
happened yeah what sometimes he just
kind of you want to suffer too long for
too long the position is so simple no I
know I understand but sometimes it just
feels so bad he don't want to resign and
this psychologically this is very hard
when you see one of your team members
lose so quickly it's kind of weird
because cze was such a solid player the
DZ Junior but now he's playing like
against different level of players I
feel like a slightly higher level of
players I mean you're looking at yeah
and US Junior you had Jeffrey Shong and
Jeffrey wonder leang and you had ruang
Lee who definitely are very very strong
players Kaden had a great showing but
yeah you had a couple of rounds where
you were playing 23 2400 players which
are strong players themselves but they
don't punish you the way this guy did
yeah playing stronger players really
shows the weaknesses in your game and I
think we have some more updates from
Christian well well well guys
materialism wins again and is not a good
sign for H black in this position he
played the move after Rook to E3 he
played the move Rook a to B8 I was
talking you don't want to defend that
pawn on B5 you want to play uh Bishop f8
try to harmonize your pieces and uh get
a dynamic Edge after Rook a rook A2 B8
Rook F3 is probably going to come on the
board Rook to d8 Queen to B3 we're going
to exchange these two pawns I'm going to
take on F7 King to h8 but now my knight
gets into play your king the light
squares around your king are very very
vulnerable and we know the action of the
queen and the Knight could be deadly
also your Bishop on on B4 what is he
doing your Bishop doesn't have any sort
of targets you will have to redirect
directed potentially to D4 the problem
is I always have the option of just
blocking that diagonal with Knight E3
once again your king is weak your pawns
are weak you have four islands of three
islands of Pawns against my two islands
of Pawns this is just a very stable uh
Advantage for white yes a solid Edge
it's not a humongous Advantage but it's
something that Sam can definitely used
to work with sometimes you just have to
try to equalize the game that activity
that the Rooks were providing the lines
that Christian was giving were very
convincing whereas now exchanging that E
Pawn for the F Pawn and the static
weakness on the light squares gives the
king that's the main problem once you
weaken the king that's a permanent
problem you're never going to fix that
King yeah I agree and that's going to
mean that for a long time Sam can press
and press and press and this is where
you can try to outplay your opponent no
matter how good he is I do expect this
move Rook F3 it looks like the most
logical um a slight Edge now for Sam
saan who can can think about pushing uh
in this slightly slightly better
position and it's funny when black
played D5 originally we said it take for
if white play C takes D5 that takes care
of so many blocks problem the bishop is
blocked the Knight cannot go to D5 there
is no D6 weakness and now in this
position it's kind of the opposite once
the E4 Pawn is gone all s under the
square for the Knight the F2 will never
ever be a Target because the Knight is
going to be such a beautiful piece and
you can never kick my knight out and
you're always going to have this E5 um
weakness so it seems like he understood
the Dynamics in this position but here
maybe he felt like there's not enough
material on the board so if I lose a
pawn this a pawn might just run right so
I don't I may not have enough
compensation whereas in the other
position he had the bishop pair which
would just naturally offer a lot of
compensation yeah I agree that this
position uh after the line that
Christian was giving it's nothing too
major it's nothing where black cannot
hold a position anymore trade of Queens
will favor Black it's hard uh to keep
the Queens alive without making it
passive Bishop on before is still quite
active it's just a nagging presence of
the light Square weakness and the King
weakness that is going to take a while
for black to to solve I wouldn't even
say fully solve but not have to deal
with immediately maybe if we trade
Queens then I don't have to worry about
my king so yeah if you trade Queen's
Black's going to be fine probably even
though you have to still deal with the
isolated E Pawn but it's probably okay
for black as long as the Queens are on
the board there are chances there are
chances although Black's still pretty
active and he still also has great
chances of equalizing that's all he's
going to be hoping for now yeah but uh
we we're Lo well I don't want to say we
the US team is losing with black pieces
so they still have the two wi so they
still have a chance of coming back and
that's kind of the nice things of
playing on a team there's a lot of
responsibility and a lot of times if you
do lose a game you just feel awful but
sometimes you lose a game and you have
your the team carry you and that feels
good know you're losing a game and then
the team still wins and you're like okay
life's not so bad my team carried me or
at least they make a draw and you know
like someone can
fix things well actually four people I
actually think the best chances we have
right now uh is with the black pieces in
the game of Arian Chopra and Ru Fang Lee
because we've seen in this position
after Knight takes D5 Bishop takes D5
black has one very good piece the bishop
on D5 but I have the potential of
activating all the other pieces while
I'm not sure what you're going to do
with these two Bishops and that's
exactly what Arian chopar is asking
himself as well and he played the move
Bishop to G5 but after Knight F6 very
wise decision keep the pieces on the
board uh keep the position as and
balanced as possible and uh the position
is still equal according to the computer
but uh from a human's perspective this
looks very very good for black queen to
B7 Rook to C8 potentially even A5 at the
right moment to try to break your
structure on the queen side try to
create a weakness on A3 I'm not really
sure what you're going to do on the que
on the king side also how are you going
to displace this bishop on D D5 you're
probably going to have to try to
exchange it at some point with uh Bishop
C4 the problem is this nagging uh
pressure on the dile simply put black
species uh they just look much more
active much better placed and uh the
Harmony in his position is superior I
think black has the upper hand I I have
a question Christian more one of those
um specifics of the position I see that
Arion has played the mo Queen
E3 and uh as the boring player that I am
I usually don't understand these kind of
sacrifices so I'm going to ask for a
little bit of help but after Bishop D6
how are you going to defend
H2 mhh I don't want to play as white
here the move H3 because I'm really
scared of Knight H5 no you don't want to
weak on your squares for sure you want
me to play G3 and then you want to
sacrifice I wanted to play G3 and if
Bishop takes G3 Pawn takes G3 Queen
takes G3 I wanted to see if I'm actually
winning this position cuz after King H1
well Alejandro and tatv you guys have a
a medal on the board Knight G4 so let's
see if you get a silver medal I will
give you a silver for winning this
position no no no for after Bishop D6
how to defend the pawn on H2 how to
defend the pawn because this is bad
right you cannot play this is bad
terrible okay so you can do this so here
is Knight G4 winning on the spot in that
position I thought there was Queen there
were some still defens that's what I
thought to in that position yeah let's
take a look just to explain to the
viewers that in this position check King
H3 let's find a killing blow here first
uh it looks like Knight G4 it's actually
not that easy it's actually not that
easy Knight G4 Queen F4 it just holds
the position together somehow so this
actually not so easy is it I don't think
you have a winning blow I think you just
have the compensation I can always draw
if I fell like it with Queen H Queen G3
I just want a little bit more than which
is what you want to do when your team's
losing you just make a quick draw and
then like you guys figure it out I'm
done but G3 is such a difficult move to
make yeah I agree yeah I agree and even
if I don't take immediately I mean the
weakness of the long diagonal in here is
kind of dangerous so you're saying
there's another way ah maybe King H1
King H1 very good Alejandro you're in
good shape today wait what kind of metal
silver silver I got PR move yeah yeah
King H1 of course because if Bishop
takes H2 I think the move F4 just traps
the bishop on on this
Square all right so got your question
answered so yeah interesting detail here
that you always have to watch out
because you see that Queen on B8 and
it's a hedgehog player I always see the
Bishops trying to harass uh the kingside
pawns from afar and sometimes it's not
so trivial to defend him but I like this
move King H1 actually a multi-purpose
move the defens on H2 not so easy for E
side to make progress then you can play
Queen B7 because you're tring Knight C6
and Knight F5 here right uh Knight C6
does look uncomfortable so I like the
move Queen B7 it defens the pishop on E7
so Knight F5 is no longer anything I
have to deal with it prepar the move
Rook K C8 Queen B7 looks like a very
logical attempt to me in this position
Queen E3 is actually a very smart move
uh because you're preparing against the
you're first of all you're getting your
queen out of the D file which is very
very dangerous and uh in the same time
you're defending that pawn on A3 and
whenever black is going to play A5
you're going to be able to respond with
a move B5 right I like that idea create
the pass Pawn defend uh the very very
important Pawn on A3 and yeah I do like
this move multi-purpose move Queen to E3
but still Black's position I think it's
preferable the problem is consequences
and one of the consequence of the move
Queen to E3 is that potentially I could
have Knight coming to D5 and attacking
that Queen so the best move in the
position is actually Bishop to B7
preparing the move Knight to D5 opening
up the dile and once again I'm trying to
take advantage of the fact that your
pieces are still uncoordinated if white
manages to coordinate his pieces then
he's going to be perfectly fine but for
the moment you still have a few pieces
under developed
uh the queen on E3 after Knight to D5
this annoying threat uh is going to have
to uh find a better placement and we're
going to see whether first of all rang
is going to play Bishop D7 he's going to
understand the consequences and after
that how is white going to defend
against it can I go KN C6 after Bishop
is s I'm assuming you're going to take
and go Knight D5 yeah I think that's
actually a little dangerous for for uh
White because Knight D5 wherever you
move the queen I'm going to exchange uh
the
Bishops and now I was going to finish it
off with uh uh something well I wanted
to kick your queen out first actually H6
Queen doesn't have good squares it's
very very and here the thing is you're
left with this bishop on E2 which is a
light squared Bishop which does not
cover the weaknesses on the dark squ I
was wondering if I can get something in
like Knight F4 I wish my Pawn was on F2
here my Pawn was on F2 be so happy cuz
my Bishop's just attacking the pawn on
A6 I think if your Pawn was on F2 You'
just be better yeah but it's not it's on
F3 and that causes a lot of problems
actually that changes the entire
evaluation of the position yeah I have
to say that I like black a little bit if
I can get away with the move Knight F4
can I take your you cannot take on A6
because I take on
A6 what am I missing everything oh kn2
and yeah but it's a coinc you don't want
to so you cannot actually play this uh I
really hate that Bishop on G5 I really
wish my Bishop was somewhere defending
the B4 Pawn so I could play push that
pawns right just Bishop G5 is so
misplays to me I mishop on G5 did look a
little bit awkward to me he wanted to
give that queen as a spot but the bishop
itself has suffered kind of wish I could
put like Queen F2 Bishop B3 almost like
I really and one thing I did like
Christian suggestion is Rook fc1 because
I wish I could P put my Rook on B1 just
push those pawns because that's where my
play is I have two against one I want to
create a pass Pawn yeah this Rook on on
F1 is actually quite misplaced I mean
there are a couple of variations where
it's useful it being on the on play
queen7 you play Queen
Bal it was thought to suggestion I agree
it's a very natural move prepares to
bring the Rook into the game Knight B3
here maybe I can like harass you a
little bit Knight B3 I think runs into
Knight G4 uh let me see if that's true
Knight B3 with the idea of playing
Knight A5 I want to play the move Knight
G4 taking advantage of your overloaded
pieces so I take I'm going to take your
Bishop okay so it has to take take back
and I take on B3 and I was wondering
this so bad I'm not sure oh because of
Bishop F3 at the end uh that's not so
good for me or actually Queen to F4 yeah
if I even have to like I this position
for black well I was trying to get you
know a long-term pass Pawn open up my
diagonal for the bishop but I I agree
that this was not such a good idea no
um let's go back so Knight B3 does look
quite logical because you're going to A5
you kind of try to exploit some of the
weaknesses on uh that side of the board
Al I wonder if I can take on D5 and then
play Knight D5
uh but I don't think I'm going to
exchange I might play Bishop D2 okay
yeah you want to keep the pair of
Bishops back to that concept I'm not
sure you can actually do this I I'm
going to try to trick you yeah have you
take and go A5 I have tricks but I'm not
sure they work your tricks some work
okay so no I'm going to take on E7 so
take no I'm not going to take on E7 what
am I saying hold on let's try to figure
this out uh oh you're pinned yourself
I'm just going to play Bishop B1 no
Bishop B3 sorry so you don't check
Bishop B 3 and you just lose the KN it's
funny how I pain myself yeah so the idea
was after Bishop before before you at A5
and you're going to win a pawn or yeah
it's a little a little tricks in the
position because it's it's quite complex
with the uh consolation of pieces we
have wait can we go back to that uh
final position now where where you
pinned yourself yeah I did something
like this like this like this and I want
to ah Queen D5 doesn't work because of
Bishop C4 yeah two Bishops in an open
position right right right very tricky
all tactics around um you out tricked
yourself no one no one how I lose a
chance I just out Trick myself but let's
let's try to play simple chest guys
let's play A5 so if B5 you have A4 A4 a
this actually looks pretty bad yeah this
looks bad for white because this
weakness of the p on A3 now is quite
palpable I mean I don't like that
position at all for uh the white pieces
so this is again the foret of putting
the rook fc1 and in this position I just
play Rook B1 and they like why why
giving me a passp I'm putting a rook
behind it and I'm just going to push it
yeah I completely agree and this is like
having a feel of the position and
knowing the idea as well and I think um
when you're playing against Shing and
and you're playing the English attack
which was played I think you're used to
castling King side and you're used to
more those to those position and those
ideas so when you Castle King side I
think um that's it's a little bit more
unnatural to you if you're English
attack player and you're used to those
positions where you're just going for a
straight up attack so you don't really
understand this um differences between
Rook C1 R C1 just they all look like
moves to basically yeah there's SL
subtleties but they actually definitely
add up so we're going to have to see
exactly what Chopra does he is falling
behind on the clock a little bit he's
almost 20 one he's actually 20 minutes
behind on the clock compared to R Lee
that we noticed in the junior
Championship he loves putting that
pressure on the clock on his opponent so
here he's combining those ideas he's a
perfectly fine position but also the
fact that he is so far ahead on the
clock I think is a great sign here for
Tim us I have to agree with Christian uh
yes we are definitely going to lose the
game of Nicholas CA with the black
pieces but ruang seems to be uh on the
better side of the position against
Arian Chopra perhaps objectively still
close to equal but I think anybody would
be taking the black pieces in that
position and Chopra knows it uh and he
knows that he has to pull the brakes uh
Exchange change pieces make a draw and
uh Salvage a half a point he knows he's
close to being edging that worst
position already yeah I think that I I
would prefer the USA position very very
very slightly on boards one two and
three and we are just completely lost on
board four right now okay and I I think
it's a very important thing to
understand when to like pull the breakes
and try to make a draw and I think this
is something that John ber like didn't
manage to do in the first round and
again like lack of experience and like
in that position when it was Quinn
versus bishop and Knight and pawn like
when you look at it like objectively I
don't know what the evaluation actually
was exactly but practically when you
have no time and your opponent has a
pass plan that's going your king is on
the other side of the board and your
opponent like he had a fortress I think
at that point I think he did have a for
yeah so I think like having that
dangerous s i be like okay I'm not
playing for win I need to make a draw
and kind of Keeping Up With The Changes
of the position I think is a very tricky
thing to do in chz in general I have a
feeling here in cze is this game do
Checkmate somewhere Well I this is
really irrelevant I mean all all I have
to do is do this and you resign I mean
night is six is made or not okay it
doesn't matter so we're we're going to
see a point here so basically this game
is over it's been over for a while and
hasn't changed it's nearing conclusion I
think very very easy would be to just
play uh maybe
E4 H4 okay H5 every move wins H every
move wins here in this position there's
no need to analyze Wes up two pawns uh
better King no counter no this is done
so one game we haven't looked at in a
while is the leaders of both teams Jeff
J versus hi mares and with did as we
mentioned that hike is coming back from
a very tough loss time yesterday and uh
that's kind of a tough situation to be
in and it's a good opportunity for
Jeffrey to keep the pressure and make
his opponent uncomfortable and
especially I think in a team tournament
that's kind of a hard thing to deal with
because you you always when you lose in
a team tournament you always have this
feeling that you let your team down
absolutely so it's kind of um weighs
heavy on you so you you know you want to
come through for your team so when
you're under pressure it's like um you
know this uh feeling that I don't want
to do the same thing again like I have
to bring point for my team yeah and in
this position he's definitely not going
to bring a point for his team he's going
to be suffering for a while but yeah but
half Point that's all he has to do he
playing Black against a much stronger
play much higher rated player so he
needs to bring this half a point back
and they're playing an extremely solid
position in which wh's spacing Advantage
given by the pawns on C5 and C6 is going
to be a permanent Edge uh here white is
just played the move Rook A1 and I'm
almost positive that if Hy decides to
take take and go Rook a that Jeffrey is
simply going to
decline the uh I don't know where the
rook's going but he's definitely going
to decline the exchange of a pair of
Rooks unless Rook no Rook A5 is met with
Bishop d8 that doesn't actually help me
I don't want to trade all the Rooks it's
basic basically what I'm trying to say
so why do you want to trade one pair of
Rooks I want to trade one pair of Rooks
because normally uh black is going to be
able to Triple down on the a file and
this at least reduces a little bit of
the pressure and sometimes this allows a
lone Queen to defend against the
intrusion of some of the enemy pieces
that being said I have seen most of the
time that white actually allows the
tripling of the pieces on uh the file
and just ignores the threats uh the move
Rook A1 with the idea of exchanging one
pair looks logical but I haven't seen it
very often so one thing that I have seen
the line you were showing like Rook A1
Rook A1 mhm so for example Rook A8 so I
move my Rook somewhere let's put it
on E1 okay and then Rook A3 yes and then
Queen B2 Rook Queen somewhere and then
Knight goes to C1 B3 A5 and The Rook
actually gets trapped yeah and then even
if you have a bishop on d8 you I disc
connect your pieces and then you
disconnect your pieces yeah see the
thing about an open file and people
always love open files but they're only
as useful as their penetration squares
and here the thing is that once you
penetrate on A3 you're not actually
going to do anything in the next move
the rook's completely controlled and
this is why white can afford to move a
rook off the file which looks
counterintuitive initially but you're
moving The Rook off the file and you're
allowing yourself to build up pressure
on the other side of the board the
reason that you keep Rooks is that when
you expand on the king side you go F3 G4
H4 or you go F3 E4 you want to have a
rook that supports that attack that is
able to swing between both sides and
cause pressure against your opponent if
you don't have any major pieces doesn't
matter how many pawns you push I mean
what exactly are you going to be
creating and for this reason many many
times you actually keep both Rooks alive
I'm slightly surprised if they move Rook
A1 but I can understand it and this is
one another concept that when you
explain to beginners Rook belong on open
file but then as you get stronger you
realize but you know it's it's all
relative and like that's what makes just
complicated all the rules that we learn
and all of a sudden like getting
stronger and you're realiz okay like
that doesn't apply this rule doesn't
apply that doesn't make sense like what
is this that I keep learning it seems
like Jeffrey is actually contradicting
you guys uh because he did play the move
Bishop d8 Queen to B2 and I think what
he's preparing right now is actually the
double uh Rook exchange on the a file
Rook takes A8 Rook takes A8 and then
Rook to A1 uh I think that one of the
problems if you don't for example Rook
takes A1 in the lines you guys were
mentioning Rook to A8 let's say Rook to
E1 um yeah Rook to E3 might be an idea
and even in this position I think you
were mentioning Knight to C1 I always
have the move Rook A1 oh never mind why
is this not working Knight 3
A2 ah okay okay so after Knight C1 I
have to play the move Knight to E4 try
to create a counterplay not allow you to
go uh Knight to B3 inside Knight Knight
a 4 F takes C4 and after Knight B3 I
think I
have did I did I have Queen A4 in that
position maybe Queen A4 yes Queen to A4
Knight to A5 still and then the Knight
the PA on C6 is hanging um I'm not
really sure but I've seen this Rook on
the a file actually create some uh havoc
in White's position and force White's
pieces to stay on the queen side if you
exchange both Rooks then all your pieces
are going to be able to just uh go on
the king go on the king side attack G4
H4 also my king is going to be able uh
to push further on the third onto the
third rank potentially and uh help with
the attack I
remember I think I exchanged both Rooks
in my game against birish and then I
expanded on the king side the only game
that I had this structure in my life and
uh I very very smooth win for for white
white black is just simply going to
suffocate at some point once again we
don't our Classics of cirilla versus um
bires the famous T Birches so we need to
learn our Classics talking about this
games and we have no
knowledge so we
have Queen be2 is playable I mean this
ideas of exchanging all the pieces and
going into something like a double night
end game it's still a position in which
Jeffrey can put some pressure but it's
supposed to be holdable um the problem
for black of course is that that's the
maximum you're going to maybe hold the
position most of the time but you're
never going to win you're never ever
going to win any of these kind of
positions because how do you ever make
progress with black what can you ever
attack how could white even
overexpanded for white is usually very
good so the only thing black is ached
here is basically traded the light squ
Bishops yeah and soon he's going to be
able to uh make the achievement of
exchanging this bishop on d8 because you
see the bishop on d8 wants to exchange
Itself by playing Bishop C7 uh of course
that also has its problems because it
does weaken certain dark squares yeah I
thought you wanted to keep your Bishop
there to stop Knight A5 or is the idea
is that once you exchange the bishop
once the Knight comes to A5 you're going
to play Knight B8 and you're going to
defend to C6 Pawn this is a very
difficult uh game for a lot of young
players to play because basically you're
sitting and you can't do anything for
the rest of the game you're just hoping
that white can't break through yeah
that's that's um I mean I guess some
players can do that but um a lot of
players don't like a lot of players hate
doing that I hate doing that just hate
it how do you feel about it I hate it
okay okay I wasn't sure no but I mean I
don't know I think okay like it's never
Pleasant to just defend but it's still a
stylistic thing some people are a lot
like mentally they're ready to defend
this kind of position and I think other
players are just full up like they
cannot see they have to make active
moves and sometimes making active moves
really backfires because the only thing
you're doing is basically creating
weaknesses I think we're going to see a
result very soon in the game of czecher
okay let take a look okay I feel like
there's meat okay oh there's an extra
piece wait what happened to the bishop
just
disappeared um I mean we had this exact
position there was a bishop Focus they
disappeared wait why can I because if
you take and take another PA check and
you take another pawn and that's three
pawns and here you just have a I mean so
many options on how to win you can try
to Checkmate the guy you can win up a
three- Pawn end game up uh he decided
that the a pawn was more valuable which
of course is uh of course it's not it's
not and now he's getting M it so he has
to play Queen G s and again after Queen
G7 I can choose how I want to win I can
just trade the queens and win because
the KN get back gets back in time I have
a check on the6 because you have a check
on yeah you have a check on E6 and I
just you know just catch your spawn
while the spawn goes forward uh I can
just uh play Queen E8 I can play Queen
H5 I can do whatever I want does not
matter at this moment I'm surprised he
hasn't resigned actually yeah I I don't
think he thinks he his chances I think
he's just playing on inertia and he just
just feels bad yeah one important thing
thing in team competition is actually to
survive as much as possible even if
you're completely lost uh it gives a
sense of camaraderie to to to your team
that you're actually putting the effort
trying to survive trying to be as
resilient as possible uh it's just
another psychological important uh
Nuance that you need to take uh take
care of I agree with that like you want
to stretch out the loss as fast as you
can even if you lost after to move 20
you want to make it like move 40 but
like Che is doing but this is not the
position you're looking and you're
saying oh there are chances like you
know it's just a matter of time so what
he should have probably done is after
like Bishop G5 H6 E6 should have sat
there for like 20 30 minutes and hope to
find something no not hope to find
something just to like stretch it out
and see like how things develop on the
other boards like what you don't need to
rush to lose the game right I what's the
difference let your opponent want to run
and and maybe your teammates think
you're trying to find something yeah and
you know otherwise if you play it and
with you see a handshake then you play
it you play it you lose and then your
team8 see and that changes the dynamic
like there's less pressure on the other
team now your team feels like they need
to win so I think his move like 20
should just said there and well a a
tough loss for Nicholas CA the world
team on the overall result is now on
plus three with this result and in in
the under 17 they're on plus two uh an
important win here for alexo very solid
player from Russia just completely
devastated uh a weak game from Nicholas
sha honestly he
did not understand when to properly
break open the position and it just
backfired very very badly on him yeah
and he had a save against Jeffrey Jean
yesterday and during the interview he
was yesterday he was so positive and he
spoke so highly of this tournament it
was like it was my dream to play here
well and he's doing very very well and I
do think for a lot of these players like
because s Lou chess club has become such
a prominent chess club in the world we
host some of the strongest players
Magnus Carlson to all the strongest soon
to
betired that's true we make them come
out of retirement if they they're
retired so I mean to be playing in the
same playing Hall and you're sitting
there and you see their photos and my
photo too of course of course I mean and
I think it's just such a like a
privilege I almost to be playing here at
this point because you know G does have
this reputation and I think for them
it's like coming to America because they
don't really have a lot of reasons or a
lot of options to come here we don't
offer that many tournaments for you
tournament not tournament with
conditions that they're used to uh it's
difficult to come all the way to uh from
Europe from Russia and to gamble in the
American opens if you will uh whereas
this is just such an elite tournament
and here the Russians are really showing
us great chess yeah and they can prepare
it and they have the team spirit and
like you said most of the players on
their team are Russian speakers so they
like it's easy for them and I think a
lot of them do come from that chess
School the chess Prof School in Russia
that produced so many students with I
think they have a relationship with each
other already being students together so
I do think they have a great Dynamics I
mean I really like I really like this
attitude yesterday he was like yeah I'm
so happy to be here as like my dream
come true well uh he has uh won the
first uh result of the day uh something
that we already expected I think since
like the first hour we did not like uh
Nicholas Checkers uh position and he
very smoothly won he gave that decisive
blow that E6 move here after the move H6
that sealed the deal after after this it
was just paperwork as they say the rest
was just signing the score sheets it was
just game over after the move E6 so
we're going to see if tomorrow he's
going to be able to recover from his win
well he has perhaps another game tonight
we're going to have to see oh that's I'm
sorry tonight yeah so yeah uh so
actually the world team did make a
strange decision in their lineup we saw
SM who won yesterday against saan did
not play and the mar who lost so badly
is actually still playing so I think
they're in a situation they cannot like
they have to let the top players play
because um because you are playing savan
and Jun who are just winning every game
and actually speaking of that I think we
have some moves in the Sean game and
everything we predict that is um
happening on the board yeah that's why
they pay us so after Rook ad d8 Queen B3
and as we predicted Queen takes C4 and
Queen takes F7 and we are talking
specifically about this position earlier
that these slightly nagging uh
possibilities against the King on h8
give Sam some hope for the advantage but
as we mentioned the possibility of Queen
trade is so prevalent and uh so good for
black that it's going to be difficult to
actually make anything concrete out of
this if Black's able to trade Queen
somehow he s solve his problems I'm
thinking Queen D4 maybe Queen D4
immediately mhm well I am h i hanging my
Rook
you wanted to try Knight F5 tricks again
no Knight F5 is definitely not wor so
Rook B1 let's move the Rook to B1 I like
The Rook on B1 it attacks the bishop and
it attacks the pawn potentially I just
don't want him to play Queen D7 because
I what you're trying what Bishop
C5 Bishop C5 oh this looks suspicious I
have to say KN F5 Knight F5 Queen D7
Queen
D6
B6 seems like black has just about
enough defensive resources to push me
away
maybe I just don't have enough pieces to
attack with I mean maybe I could have
played Queen H5 and not run into a Tempo
at least Queen H5 here and maybe try to
play Knight H4 Knight G6 I was thinking
Knight H6 but
sure all right or that yes Knight H6
also a threat I'm not sure if it's a
threat but it's there Queen
E6 Queen E6 I don't know if I play Queen
E6 then I I think after Queen E6 Queen
G4 I start getting the kind of positions
I really do want to play I'm going to
going to play Rook to E1 I'm going to
play Rook to E4 I'm going to bind you on
the light squares I'm going to play H4
H5 and yes you're not dead but no I
agree that's that starts becoming
unpleasant those the things that black
has to watch out for I think Queen H5 is
actually a quite clever move I wouldn't
be surprised if you actually have to
play the move E4 at some point because
E4 always prepares the move E3 and it
opens up the bishop for a potential
defense here on uh on G7 if I really
really need it
uh too bad I wanted to take things and
then C5 hangs but my Rook is hanging
your Rook is currently hanging so Rook
C3 have Bishop
D4 yeah that's what I was thinking
something like Bishop D4 actually here
Bishop F2 wins wa I want to go to G3
where'd you go I C3 because it was a
Tempo oh well this is also a Tempo wait
why is this why is this uh I wanted to
play Bishop D4 and then Rook
G6 actually is a little dangerous yeah
the position still retains quite a bit
of danger for black uh he has to be
careful here and this is the position
that we have on the board Knight G3 and
uh the queen is currently under attack
Queen D5 is what I thought was more
natural because of the tempo against uh
the
queen so I'm actually starting to
understand that Christian's bishop f8
move more and more yeah the bishop
actually was very well placed on f8
whereas on B4 it's a Target yeah because
if we go back to that line again where
Queen B3 came it was a double attack on
the bishop and the pawn and pl really
didn't want to lose that pawn but maybe
here he felt that he has enough that
even losing the pawn on F7 he has enough
counter play and defense to I mean he
might be right but it's not going to be
easy it's not going to be easy to defend
for the rest of the game in the other
case it was him that had the initiative
even if he was down a pawn and that was
the easier way of playing the position I
mean I think giving up a pwn is also not
easy so it was like Crossroads which
position he wanted to play like play
down the pawn dynamically or try to
defense um so we still have a lot of
three games going on we have three games
going on yeah and uh the games are still
developing so we are going to take a
little bit of a break and don't go
anywhere we will be right
[Music]
back there's
AEK one tank in a
City St
Louis fun so much fun for your family
Infinity a t there's Museum full of Art
and super fun slides upside down
concrete twisty turny rides Houses full
of magic Su with butterflies Gardens
growing flowers
eyes I'm Mike manager of the Cardinals
and chess fanatic at the world-renowned
chess club and Scholastic Center of St
Louis across from the World Chess Hall
of Fame St Louis status as the chess
capital of the nation is on Full display
with a welcoming environment and
Scholastic outreach program that works
with over over 100 Schools our goal is
to teach play and promote the sport so
whether you've played for years or never
before we invite you to experience all
chess has to
[Music]
offer
what
[Music]
w
n
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back this is
round five of the under 17 section SE
section of the Millennial Match U my
name is Sav Abraham and I'm in the
studio with Alandra Ramirez we're coming
back from a break and as we're coming
break we did have a game finished that
we look at which which means the world
team is actually now leading by three
points over the US team which means us
team needs some major wins to not only
come back or try to tie the match or if
they have any hope of winning this match
somehow they need to make some big
comebacks in this match to win this one
or at least tie and uh do something in
the remaining three matches but so far I
don't think it's looking very good for
us not great a very Dem demoralizing
loss there by Nicholas cze who really
fell without a fight he was destroyed
from the very opening as we see here the
standings after round four this does not
include uh the game of Nicholas cha so
this is the standings coming into
today's round and you have to add
another point to the world team yeah and
then in the evening we're going to have
the under 14 section and then as we're
mentioning the under 14 section the US
is actually uh struggling in because uh
the world team is actually um higher
rated than us so this this today is
going to be a very tough day in the
office for the American team so they
need to figure out what is it that
they're not doing
right uh so let's take a look what's uh
going on in this round so we already
have one result Alex s beat Nicholas
Czech in that game that uh we went over
uh before we took a break so Arian Chapa
is still playing against R Fang Lee
Andre yeno versus Sam savian and Hike
martus versus Jeffrey drank so the score
so far is 9 and 1 half to 7 and A2 and
the world team is extending their lead
over the American team at least the two
high rated players with the white pieces
here Jeffrey Shong and Sam SE are
putting pressure on their opponents but
can they break through that's going to
be a very tough question to answer as
their opponents are putting very stiff
resistances both games already with a
reduced amount of material and we're
going to have to see if the pressure
that is given by their positions is
going to be enough to actually reel in
at least one of them as a full point so
let's take a look at Jeffrey game so we
were talking about not exchanging pieces
not heavy pieces and then we're coming
back to position with no heavy pieces no
have no pieces at all you have two
knights uh for uh per side and that's
going to be it Black's obviously very
solid but very passive as this Pawn on
C6 is going to be a permanent permanent
weakness in the position uh white black
already has to decide which Knight he
wants to use to defend uh the pawn on C6
and afterwards White's going to try to
expand on the king side push the Pawns F
you imagine F3 G4 H4 H5 everybody's
going to go forward try to create a
secondary weakness on the king side try
to win it somehow how that's not so
clear and uh that's the plan black can't
really win it's almost impossible for
black to win these kind of positions uh
he has an uncomfortable defense for the
next uh 50 60 moves but when how many
moves 50 60 moves but uh whether he can
hold or not we're going to have to see
but this it's a two result game
basically completely two result game I
think one of the only ways of uh
actually trying to win in this position
is at the right moment after my
expansion on the king side I would
assume he's going to put this Knight on
uh B8 maybe it's not correct the Knight
on A6 will limit this Knight's movement
because he has to defend the pawn on B4
I'm going to play F4 G4 H4 bring my king
to the uh to the center and then at the
right moment I think the only way white
could try to create uh some uh
destabilizing ideas would be to play
this move Knight B7 Knight to D6 reroute
the Knight and perhaps even at the right
moment sacrifice that knight uh for a
few pawns and uh try to take advantage
of Black's passivity and lack of space
but uh this is uh this is a long shot
the computer actually really likes
White's position he's all he's he's
giving an almost plus one advantage uh
but I'm not really sure if this is
winning
we we'll have to wait and see yeah today
is going to be another long day for us
but of course this is what needs to be
done for Team USA and if this is what it
takes to win a game then this is what
you have to do you have to play 50 60
moves and try and try right and again
you're playing a two result game so the
pressure basically is on your opponent
to defend but at the same time they're
kind of playing with a safety because I
don't think tying the match is such a
terrible result for the world team they
are leading yes with three runs to go in
this section and two runs to go in the
other section so there's still five
matches left but uh in the under 14
section they're they're not having any
problems so they need to at least hold
these matches and then I think they're
they're pretty sad they haven't lost a
single one to me it's slight surprising
they haven't lost a single one of the
under 17 matches to me this was where
we're going to get them right I thought
they can just dominate I thought us team
would just dominate the under 17 section
and and kind of get Crush in the under
14 and because there are more games in
the under 17 I thought this is how us
would win this match but I mean it's
great to see the tournament to be more
competitive and uh watching the US team
you know they have to they're playing on
their home turf so they have to prove um
to prove it and this could turn around
that any moment there's a lot of points
being fought at at any given match so
still plenty of uh of recovery time here
for Team USA so I think we have some
more updates from Christian I think our
Chopra is doing exactly what we were uh
trying to uh push him to do and uh
exchange the Rooks pull the brakes and
make a draw he did exchange the Rooks on
the C file now his uh pieces are
starting to harmonize uh their position
and after Bishop E3 I only see a plan
for black and that is E5 E4 try to break
the structure try to create some action
on the diagonal for the bishop on D5 but
that's going to be very very difficult
uh to do because whenever you play E5
the consequence of that move is that
you're giving a very very unpleasant
Square for uh for the Knight on F5 and
the Knight is going to be able to create
a lot a lot of danger around the king
coupled with the action of the bishop on
E3 the queen on C1 on this diagonal so I
think this is very very close uh close
to a draw none of the players have an
active plan at their disposal yeah it's
a kind of a position where if you try
too hard you actually fall into a worse
position uh Chopper's done well lately
with the amount of time he's consumed in
moves and the more simplified the
position gets the easier it is to play
even in time pressure rank does play the
move Bishop D6 a very logical idea to
put some pressure in the king side you
put some pressure in the dark squares uh
allows you to perhaps potentially play
the move Queen B8 at some point he has
to be a little bit careful that any
further trades and you're going to be
playing an end game in which white has
the famous queenside majority of course
when I was a kid I never understood the
definition of a Queens side majority
what why is it the different thing about
being a Queens side or a king side the
what the which party didn't answer the
queen side of the majority but I don't
understand why a Queens side majority
would be inherently better than a
kingside majority and the reason that
such a concept exists is because in the
majority of games people Castle King
side and therefore the queen side is
actually further away from the castle
position of the king but of course uh in
the case that we have a double Queen
side castling which is very rare then
the king side majority would be what's
important in this case because we have
two pawns on this flank it's going to be
difficult for black to stop them in for
example a pawn end game or a bishop end
game since the King on Jade is so far
away so he has to pull the braks on the
amount of pieces he traced from now on
and Chopra may try to use that to his
Advantage as uh Christian was saying the
idea of E5 E4 is quite tempting to open
up uh the position give him easier
access to the opponent's king and to
perhaps a pass Pawn on that side of the
board but as he also was mentioning this
Knight coming to F5 is so annoying on
that square I wouldn't go as far as
saying that I prefer uh or to say that I
I give white a slight Edge but I would
prefer being white already in this
position this Pawn on A6 strikes me as
being quite weak and something that I
perhaps could uh Target with my queen
and my Bishop I already have Queen F1
here no I already have things like Queen
F1 in which black has to be uh quite
careful on how to proceed immediately I
think you don't want to give up uh Queen
C7 and taking on
H2 as uh your king might be quite quite
weak I can go G3 you can go G3 but then
iing the suspicious area again yeah
you're entering those suspicious areas
where you are allowing your opponent
sacrifices you're allowing opponent some
C amount of counterplay you might not be
willing to do uh so specific and
concrete ideas of course already in the
position uh but I wouldn't be too happy
about playing such an unnatural move as
Queen F1 unless I'm absolutely certain
it Nets me that pawn on A6 but I mean
it's safe to say that white has
neutralized any kind of activity black
hand position still Anything could
happen in this game but I do like the
way that Chopra has been handling the
situation no I agree because we did say
he needs to exchange some pieces to
because there was a lot of pressure from
black side um mhm with the D5 uh break
coming in at the right time and you know
on once black plays D5 and the activity
is coming in so he needed to exchange
some pieces get the you know neutralize
the position and once you neutralize the
position then you can see if you want to
maybe maybe make a draw or you know you
want to play for more and um I think
anything can still happen in this match
but I do still think that uh the world
team is going to win and we do have a
full day ahead of us and uh as this
tournament is developing and actually
approaching it end we do have two only
two days left of this tournament we have
two more tournaments coming up as we do
have the summer of Chess and this is
second second leg of the summer of chz
we did just have the US junior
Championship WRA up so our next very big
event is going to be singfield cup I
believe the players should be arriving
in the next few days as they try to
arrive
for this magificent event we have the
top players in the world competing in
both legs of the grand chest T that are
going to be happening in St Louis of
course the sinfield Cup being the
classical portion of the tournament and
the St Louis rapid and Blitz being uh
the faster one with a very special wild
card in that tournament yeah we're going
to see gar Kasparov coming out of his
retirement and uh I think during the
opening ceremony he said that his
retirement resumes right after this
tournament so if you're going if you
want to see c pro players you need play
you need to be right here in St Louis
watching him play
live and uh because like when you watch
casar play you really feel the intensity
of him playing so it's something you
want to see in real life and our
tournament is actually going to wrap up
tomorrow we have two more uh we have one
more game that's going uh that's coming
up tonight at 5:00 p.m. and we our
tomorrow's round is going to be at 9:00
a.m. we're going to have an earlier
round so again the under 17 section will
will play and then in the evening at 400
p.m. the under 14 and under 17 section
will be playing the last round uh so we
will know tomorrow who won this
tournament because they're different
categories under 14 under 17 and there's
a combined trophy for winning both
tournaments so you can actually win one
lose one yeah and then and then yeah
because it's not uh match points it's
board points points so winning for Zer
is actually more
significant cuz I don't think this is
the case with the Olympia Olympia
doesn't matter how you win it just just
by tie breaks at the end of the day
which happen to be very important in
this Olympiad but doesn't mean that it's
true in every single case in the
Olympiad usually match points are the
most important here every single Half
Point counts on every single board yeah
so definitely if you cannot if you can
salvage half a point at the end it's
going to add up so it's very important
to put as much pressure as you can but I
think it's still you still have to worry
more about winning a match than than
anything else yeah than anything else
because that's those points are going to
add up too uh let's take a look at Sam
saian game I see we have some
developments this is the this is the
position we're talking about what didn't
don't think about many developments not
as many developments after Knight G3
Queen to C4 once again black is trying
to exchange that Queen is extremely
extremely important if he can manage to
uh snatch the Queens off the board the
bishop is going to become a s a
Powerhouse if it lands on D4 but after
Queen 5 there are some tricks in the
position for example if you try to
reroute this bishop Bishop C5 is still
probably the best move in the position
now you cannot take on E5 uh because
Bishop D4 is coming going to lose the
Rook on A1 so after Bishop C5 I'm going
to play a move such as Knight to H5 a
very very tricky move because right now
if you play a move such as Bishop D4
very natural the problem is Knight to F6
comes on the board and this is just game
over Checkmate will be landing because G
takes F6 Queen takes F6 and you don't
have any defense on the seventh rank
after uh King to H7 Queen to E7 King to
h8 and I'm simply going to put my Rook
on the six rank the H6 Pawn is going to
fall and uh the action of the queen
coupled with the action of The Rook is
just going to be deadly so black still
has to uhep some mindes after this move
Queen to F5 which I think is very
enterprising trying to keep control of
the light squares as much as possible
keep the Queens on the board uh but
still with precise play Black is
definitely salvaging half a point in
this position what was your prediction
for this
match forgot you make one uh but yeah we
just once again we do see the weakness
of the light Square which is something
we talk about and it's great to have a
knight in this position putting on e4 or
H5 that being said I wasn't terribly
fond with the positioning of the queen
on uh F5 because I understand sent this
Knight H5 Knight F6 trick but I felt the
queen belongs somewhere else and it was
the Knight that I wanted to put on F5 to
pressure the pawn and G7 and the Knight
is just overall more useful in a square
like F5 where it controls a lot of
potential uh tricks like on E7 on H4
whereas on H5 yes I have the trick on F6
but once I cover that square and it
should be not be a problem and once I
cover G7 the knight's not coming back
into the game in such a natural fashion
but the question is how are you going to
uh how are you going to do that where
are you going to put your queen this KN
F6 idea is very annoying actually
because after Queen G6 I play Rook D6 I
continue chasing that Queen say perhaps
I just didn't have a good Square for my
queen wait why could I go to H5 perhaps
good to H5 is the best but but then
again you're not going to couple that
action with an Queen on H5 the Knight on
F5 is not going to be as your knight on
F5 is going to be attacking H6 but
you're not attacking
g73 Rook B6 I think it's another
idea maybe Rook f8 Rook F yeah Rook f8 R
so Rook G3 Rook F6 I'm considering Rook
F6 as well maybe just start putting
things on uh the king side you want to
play Queen F7 pretty soon again this oh
yeah of threat of trading the queens and
it seems hard to make progress here for
Sam obviously the one with the
initiative but not easy to do much with
it can we go back to the position we
have on the board absolutely can I try
Rook
f8 uh well Rook E8 was just played
instead of the move we were expecting I
think Bishop C5 Rook eight I don't like
it's a little passive but you were
trying to put the Rook on f8 I take your
Pawn I take your pawn and I just realize
after Rook F2 my B8 P which is how
actually s plundered upon Pawn yesterday
yeah but quite honestly this looks
perfectly fine to me oh because you have
Bishop C5 I have Bishop C5 at the end
the queen is very active I this destroy
the coordination of White's pieces but I
think I I actually want to take on F3
with the
pawn look at you break my structure but
that pawn on F3 potentially if it lands
somewhere on F6 I'm going to be able to
open up your king you might be in
trouble that's that's a big yeah that's
very ambitious okay so Rook
f8 I mean I still think that Black's
nearly okay in this position I'm not
saying that he's equalized fully but
Queen E4 maybe yeah something like Queen
E4 but okay don't I have Queen C3 I like
Rook F4
honestly you don't like pawns I don't
like pawns I think Rook F4 is just you
love pawns alandro stop lying I do love
pawns but this looks great I mean if you
take on C4 I'm going to start thinking
about winning I still like Queen C3
Queen C3 is probably perfectly
fine actually no after where do you
go I don't know somewhere not the
easiest but I have to agree that all
these moves make a little more sense to
me than Rook e eight which I find to be
quite passive
but I think he's already on this path of
just defending and it started with
playing Rook B8 and he just wants to
hold his position the together and like
he played that D5 Dynamic move and he
got to this position but I think his
mindset has shifted he didn't continue
the same um yeah of thought for now this
is perfectly fine I mean I don't see any
tactical reason why rookie eight should
fail and of course here I mean I want to
play something like Knight H5 and try to
create some tricks on the Kings and
unfortunately with the Knight on H5 this
is all it is tricks if they don't work
the Knight on H5 is not great yeah I was
trying to go Knight D4 after Rook E8 it
seemed like I'm going to centralize my
knight and uh I'm going to limit this
bishop on B4 but the problem is Rook f8
right now is much more potent because
Queen takes C5 just loses after rook f8
and the Knight on e4 is hanging so uh
Rook E8 is quite a quite a wise idea by
the Russian player we do have a move we
have the move A3 asking the bishop where
he wants to go but more importantly it
removes the pawn from that attack by the
queen on C4 which allows this Rook on A1
to transfer somewhere at Le at least a
little bit more active was also
considering the move Rook B1 which did
something very similar without
committing the pawn to A3 as a Pawn on
A2 is obviously taboo because of the
bishop here so A3 is on the board and
the bishop has to retreat well you still
have the Rook on F3 so A3 is not really
going to be a Target it's just a matter
of maybe them playing before and trading
in more pieces and then eventually just
going to fizzle to draw because there
are no pieces left I'm assuming the
bishop goes back to C5 I don't like
putting it on f8 where it just kind of
Is On The Way of the Rook I don't like
putting it on D6 as it does absolutely
nothing I don't like putting it on E7 as
again it's on the way of The Rook this
time on the E5 so Bishop C5 is what I
think is most logical I actually wanted
to play this without provocation if I
remember correctly Christian was telling
us about the move Bishop C5 before the
move Rook E8 so this also looks fine and
and uh I have to calculate out Knight E4
I think he wants to put the Rook on E1
that was part of the reason he played
the move A3 Rook on E1 and attack this
Pawn directly so Bishop D4 on gu um I
don't necessarily want my Bishop here
but if I can get away with it perhaps
I'm always scared of this Rook E4 Rook
G4 Knight H5 I might counter playay
without the bishop on C5 I can never
play Rook f8 yeah I mean without with a
bishop on D4 so committed my king feels
like kind of naked because I don't have
Rook f8 like I cannot swing something
over to the king side to protect the
dark squares in any way like if you play
any kind of sacrifice like I can never
play bishop f8 and defend my H6 Pawn so
I mean Bishop on D4 like it looks like a
great piece it's in the Central Square
but at the same time it's not
coordinating with anybody it looks a
little scary yeah it's the king side
that you have to be very scared about in
this position and the bishop on D4 is
just completely out of play I have to
agree that I don't quite like this uh
idea of Bishop D4 a big problem because
of the Pawn on A3 is that you right now
have the move Rook to
f8 Rook to f8 Queen takes C5 Rook takes
F3 and uh the pawn on A3 is actually
going to hang in this position uh there
a big difference um well G takes F3 Rook
goes to f8 I'm going to attack uh this
Pawn on F3 this Pawn on A3 is attacked
as well you have a lot of weaknesses
your structure is not as powerful and
the bishop on C5 is creating some sort
of attack on this diagonal for example
if you play the move Knight F5 which
looks quite uh natural and very powerful
the problem is I have this uh cute
little tactic Bishop takes F2 uh
simplifying the position completely and
after King takes F2 queen to queen goes
to C2 Rook goes to E2 Queen takes F5
this is just game over
drop well it seems like Asen is holding
his own here against Sam savian even in
this uh slightly worse position
meanwhile we have uh there's some
developments in the Jeffrey game I see
he has managed to push his kingside Pawn
his Central PA done he has done this he
push all his pawns your and push your
Pawn there's no other way to make
progress in this position the thing is
how far is he going to go uh from this
point on uh black has decided to put one
of his Knights on a passive position on
B8 no real Choice there he needs to keep
the defense on C6 but I need now he has
a knight on f8 that can perhaps go
places uh after the move G4 I'm
imagining which place is it going I'm
imagining he was going to go g
G6 I'm not sure where he goes after that
but here the question and the
uncomfortable part for Black's uh setup
is that he needs to figure out where uh
he's going to create weaknesses or which
weaknesses he's going to create in order
not to lose the entire board on space
now he could just sit back and wait for
white to keep pushing all the pawns all
the way to the six rank but sometimes
that means oh yeah I'm going to go F4 G5
H5 H6 I'm going to I see I'm going to
push them all the way up if you let me
so I'm going to try to zuk Wang you it's
basically what it's going to can I just
always wait with my king or you just
going to Target my weaknesses I'm going
to try to Target Two weaknesses at the
same time and zong you the art like you
have to create two weaknesses to win the
game right that's a terrible book and I
don't read books and uh so here black
has to decide where this weaknesses are
going to be created or how how he's
going to hold on to the king side in
order not to let White have any real
resources this is why G5 was so
appealing now move like e takes D takes
E4 changes the character of the position
completely because this means that white
always has the option of playing a D5
break opening up uh the path for the C
pawn something that black really has to
be worried about on the other hand now
black also has the possibility of
creating counterplay on the king side
and I'm never worried about white
advancing the king side pawns because
cuz that's just never going to work the
only thing that I have to be worried
about is a D5 break so again options
here for hike Marty rosian and he needs
to um figure out his configuration his
defensive configuration yeah that's a
hard thing to do if you want to leave
the pwn structure as it is or change
because Pawn structure changes are
permanent but I would be terrified of
taking only4 no I me too taking on e4 is
something that I would it would do like
like last Stitch resource like I Canin
see this Pawn smothering me and I'm just
going to have to take on e4 but for now
I don't see any need I still think the
move G5 to me looks very logical so it
doesn't leave any poppable weakness
after G5 can I try something like E5 or
you going to go F6 now I have two ches
yeah either Knight D7 or F6 I believe
yeah I could go for E5 or I could also
take on D5 in a opportune moment because
if I can get you to trade both pawns and
then perhaps this Knight can jump around
uh and take advantage of the weakened F5
Square again a lot to consider uh
because as you said as Pawn structures
changes are permanent and in this case
there's so many of them that can
actually happen he has to be careful on
which pawns he pushes and which pawns he
decides to leave in the
seventh so well you only have two pawns
on the seventh but they're important I
mean they they might be the last pawns
you to to fall because if you live a
Pawn on h s you can imagine it is going
to be Target at some point and this is
an important thing to really understand
and learn about chust in general that
pawn pushes are permanent and of course
we know this we know the basic rule that
you push a pwn the pwn never comes back
but you have to realize in the long term
sometimes if you push the wrong Pawn the
evaluation of the position completely
changes like in the chopper game we're
saying if the pawn was back on F2 the
the evaluation would be completely
different but since the pawn is on F3
and there are some King weaknesses then
it's different and the same thing in
this position you have the PA pawns with
H7 G7 if you push the wrong one then
it's completely going to change the
position and I have this uh like my
students sometimes make this mistake
like they'll push a pawn and I say like
why' you do this and like I'm waiting
making a waiting move and I said like
you can never make a waiting move with a
pawn no that doesn't make sense yeah
well I mean in the end game maybe if
you're passing the move to your opponent
but otherwise making then you're
changing the nature of the position know
the point is to like keep the position
the same and pass the move to your
opponent so once you push a pawn that
changes the pawn structure and the don't
come back speaking of this entire theme
let's take a look at rank's last move as
a pawn move there was a a strange but
and committ pawn move we had this
position after Bishop D6 that we left
off the Aran CH fre League game after
Queen C3 Knight H5 is trying to
infiltrate on F4 CH pra said no no no
you're not coming in here I mean after
G3 the Knight is completely locked out
of the game and rring said excuse me I
do really want the F4 Square for myself
the move F5 is Comm middle I very
Dynamic move very Dynamic move the idea
of course to blast open the king side
with the move F4 it is a serious threat
on the other hand you can already see
how the pawn on E6 has become a weakness
because it's already being targeted by
the Knight on D4 the king is suffering a
little bit because of this as he's
opened up a couple of uh diagonals
against it choer has retreated the
bishop to F2 a move that makes a lot of
sense so F4 is not a Tempo F4 is not a
Tempo that allows me to just close down
the position on the king side not give
you the F4 Square as of course F3 does
become a little bit of a weakness but so
does your Pawn on E6 and your Pawn on F4
a committal approach here by ruing Ley
let's see if he's able to back it up
with Dynamic and conrete play in order
to justify the weakness that he's just
he has just created I would add another
weakness to your list Alejandra and that
is the Pawn on A6 and a maneuver such as
Knight B3 Knight C5 is very very
dangerous in the position playing here I
think a little bit he's playing on the
ambitious role sometimes with this kind
of positions here you're running out of
plans right you already has Christian
was mentioning not so easy to see what
to do with either side you didn't want
to play a E5 because of Knight F5 so you
kind of have to come up with something
you want to keep up the pressure you
don't want to just play random moves you
want to play something that makes sense
but after Knight H5 F G3 F5 it's not
about making sense or not making sense
it's the fact that the game has changed
from a position in which you don't know
what plans are to something very
concrete and very committal this Pawn
advances are as weakening as they are
dangerous and if Chopra can manage to
take the wind out of this attack black
is going to be left with a couple of
weaknesses and he's going to be hoping
that he could have put the pawn back
where it was I agree but uh with the
bishop on D5 I don't think the pawn on
E6 is such a weakness now it's just more
of a longterm Pro is that that Bishop is
not necessarily going to live forever if
I can put my Bishop on C4 then I'll have
a queen on
D5 well that's uh that's something no
but I mean I don't think black's attack
is so dangerous is like anything because
I don't even see where I think he wants
to continue after F4 G4 Knight F6 let's
say a move such as Knight B3 very
natural to put a knight on C5 I think he
wants to play a E5 E4 I thought he
wanted to play Knight G4 and Bishop
H1 uh but then Bishop F1 oh yeah okay
yeah this doesn't quite work because of
this bishop F1 and and seems like
everything's covered reversed yeah and
for but E5 definitely makes sense D5 E4
break open the center by force uh try to
get counter play doesn't matter if it
cost me my A6 point I'm going to
Checkmate this guy uh this is uh
completely risky from reang leag I I
think he felt the need to win a game he
hasn't won a game in the entire
tournament he has two draws in loss and
true I think that he feels the need to
prove a little bit in that position he
sees he senses the weakness of his
opponent on the clock and he says okay
this is risky but this is what I'm going
to go for he's Burning Bridges right now
he has definitely burn Bridges and we do
know he's the kind of player who doesn't
shy away from complications he will he
will he doesn't wait for the
complication to occur he'll like sck
them out yes as we know as we've seen in
the US Junior sacrificing pieces and
everything and actually it be
interesting if we can get them after the
rounds to he
how this uh results so early on
influenced the dynamic of the team if
they fa the need they need to win the
tournament standings are down by uh well
their team is um down by one point
overall they're down by two points if
they feel like they need to win if he
felt he personally felt the need that he
needs to do something or he just
objectively thought oh I have an attack
and this is what I'm going to do because
I think objectively this is the best
move I can play he's usually very true
to his style I think that these are the
kind kinds of positions that really jump
at him the ideas of breaking through of
sacrificing pieces of getting the
complications of not being afraid of
leaving weaknesses on yourself uh
sometimes irreparable weaknesses but in
this case he just wants to counter it
with the initiative with the dynamic and
specific uh options that the position is
giving him so this is very reang if I
had to categorize a move like Knight H5
F5 it's very reang to do something like
this
no yeah definitely this is his style and
like you said he's playing through his
style and and that's uh great yeah it's
good for us as we're going to definitely
see a interesting game at this position
ruang is going to try to put the
pressure especially with the short time
control that's coming up yes and they
have how much 13 minutes versus 23
minutes which is still a lot of time but
he's the one who has more time on the
clock so he's able to put pressure on
his opponent and he eats opponent is
going might find himself in trouble
trying to scrumble in U time trouble uh
let's take one more look at the saan
game before we take a break see if we
have any developments as we looked at
every all the other games uh that's
white is trying black is trying very
hard to exchange Queens after A3 Bishop
C5 Rook E1 was played attacking the pawn
on E5 Queen E6 once again chasing uh
this queen Swap and I'm expecting a move
maybe Queen C2 or queen B1 Queen B1
looks much more natur
uh to the naked eye but unfortunately
after a move such as Rook f8 I think the
position just becomes very very equal
after Knight E4 okay I'm defending the
pawn on F2 I am centralizing my knight
but uh I don't think I can take here
because of Queen takes B5 and then
you're going to have some problems
defending the pawn on E5 B position this
position even that position but if I can
get the Queens off the board and this
Pawn on E5 that's definitely that's
definitely uh pushable I guess
uh and uh after Knight E4 I think the
best move once again we're not going to
be materialistic we're going to uh put
the bishop on the best position on D4
keeping this action on the pawn on F2
after Queen takes B5 Queen goes enters
The Fray with Queen to A2 attacking both
the F2 and the A3 and this is just going
to be uh simplified in a matter of moves
I'm going to take the pawn on
A3 Queen H5 was played actually
Christian Queen
I think this this is more natural
because white is just committed to that
King side absolutely absolutely I mean
you put all your pieces there you can I
mean queen B1 didn't look natural to me
to be honest the problem is I need to
find a way to get this Rook into the uh
into the play and I think Rook A8 Rook
A4 or Rook takes A3 might be the right
way now the question is okay Knight E4
seems very natural are you going to take
my Pawn that is the question my guess is
no but uh I think there's a very clear
tactical reputation there because Knight
G5 right I think Rook F6 is much more po
Rook F6 and this is just uh looking very
very ugly you have to play a move such
as Queen to D7 wait what happens if I
take what if I just said be material
stick but you know should I give you a
medal for this one yes I don't think I
should I I have a feeling this is I
think I can find the first move okay
Queen takes H6 King to
G8 don't look at at the engine
we're not we're not Eagles you can't see
that I'm going to give you maybe uh
another silver medal for this one a
silver medal easy easy tative I think
you should have the first chance okay
okay okay Rook uh Rook E3 there we go
Rook 3 E3 we're bringing the last uh
piece into the attack uh temp G3 is
coming on the board this is just uh Game
Over N this is this this came out of
nowhere
almost all a sudden black is not going
to allow this wait so you have a threat
of Rook F6 no the knights on G3 sorry so
but this is what White's trying to do
he's trying to create that pressure on
the king side put the uh ideas of
sacrificing something along those lines
to make the king uncomfortable it's this
entire idea in this position what else
can he do at this point he's just
committ he's committed he's committed to
doing something if he doesn't do that
he's just going to pet her out to a draw
there's nothing that he can really play
for there's just one weakness yeah I
have a feeling after that 17 moved Dr
with white he was told don't this ever
again you got to try you got to try and
he's doing it he's he's at least putting
some pressure whether he's successful or
not that's a different matter as penu is
I think playing a solid game I think
he's been playing well so far and we're
going to see if Sean can break through
and we see this a lot in the Grand
Master games an equal position and one
person is trying and then the opponent
makes a mistake and that's how you wi
like at some point someone needs to make
a mistake and as we were saying like the
bishop D4 move we didn't want to put the
bishop there because Knight E4 Rook F6
all this ideas coming and so we have
still have a lot of action going on we
already have one result so Team USA is
in this round alone the Team USA is down
by a point so it is on the rest of them
Jeffrey Jang um ruang Ley and some savan
to try to come through and at least tie
the match so we're still going to have a
lot of action coming up and we're
approaching time trouble very soon so
we're going to take a break right now
and don't go anywhere we'll be right
[Music]
back
Healthcare in America is changing
evolving and we're helping lead the
transformation Ascension is made up of
Physicians and other caregivers called
to deliver compassionate personalized
care for all as one of the largest
providers of care in the country our
patients benefit from collaboration
between hospitals medical practices and
Healthcare innovators Nationwide
Ascension faith-based Heritage means we
have a moral obligation to serve
everyone especially those who are
struggling last year we provided almost
$2 billion in care for people living in
poverty and for programs to help them
whether it's in a hospital a
Neighborhood clinic a senior living
facility or at home ascensions care
providers value every aspect of our
patients lives and health we listen with
respect to ensure every person we serve
gets the right care for them
personalized compassionate
that's
[Music]
Ascension
oh
[Music]
should
oh
[Music]
e
[Applause]
[Music]
for
welcome back everyone if you're just
joining us this is round five of the
under 17 section of the Millennial Match
held right here in the chess club and
Blasting Center of St Louis my name is
Sav Abrahim I'm in the studio with
Alejandra Ramirez and as we're coming
back from the break we have some huge
development in in several of the games
that are still going we do have already
one result so us team L on the last
sport Nicholas czecho losing that game
against San so we left off um in the
jeffre r game we're thinking that a two
old game white is going to be pressing
for a while we're trying to figure out
how white is going to be pressing what
is black going to do what is um black
needed to make some committal decisions
for some pawns we W sure which ones and
as we're coming back the position
position has changed completely well it
seems like white has uh perhaps
overestimated his chances clearly
nothing has happened here so far and you
inspect the king E3 or King G3 or
something along those lines but perhaps
fearing that Black's going to play
Knight G6 and put an end to the plan of
H4 def play the move H4
immediately um I'm not sure about this
if you take on H4 immediately as black
then yes this is completely Justified as
I play the move E5 and then the king
will March up to H3 and and I will
gobble up the pawn on H4 and I have
serious winning chances even though here
black might still hold after d takes E4
however after the exchange of Pawns the
move E5 is not so feasible anymore and
this bwn on the H4 square is not
actually going to die it's going to stay
alive for a while so what's the
difference between E5 here and E5 in the
other position well E5 in the other
position uh first of all uh the fact
that I don't have a D5 break makes the
position is much worse and after the
move for example Knight G6 I am not
entirely sure how you're going to play
as uh White remember that without the
pawn on F3 I'm not going to be able to
push my Pawn to F4 so here in this
position uh King G7 King H6 King G5
can't really be avoided at some point uh
you would like to push F4 F5 at some
position but you just can't so the
inclusion of the move D takes C4 is
definitely good for black and the
transfer of the Knight KN uh that black
white has achieved to
D6 um I'm not sure what it does I mean
the Knight on
D6 doesn't really do anything it looks
very pretty it's it's an anchor Knight
on the opponent's camp but it doesn't
actually attack any key Square it's not
even in a close proximity of attacking
any of the key pawns that I want to be
pressuring so I don't really know what
this Knight does now to say that White's
going to be in a real trouble I'm not
sure about that either I mean this
double pawns on the H fou don't cause a
great impression well the problem is uh
Knight to A6 was played on the board
Knight to A6 King to H3 very natural
move to attack the pawn on H4 and uh try
to stuck this Knight on G6 to the
defense of the Pawn on H4 the problem is
uh right now after the move such as E5
I'm not really sure how you're going to
keep the balance in the center if you
play the most natural move which is D5
I'm going to defend that pawn and at the
right moment I have the option of
actually attacking uh this this Pawn
with a move Knight to C7 after the
exchange on C6 I'm going to transfer the
Knight to E6 and the problem is you're
lacking the key squares uh that you
would like your Knights to jump to for
example after Knight to C8 I'm simply
going to go Knight to C7 and now you
don't have this check on E7 I'm not
really sure your Knights are a little
bit passive they don't find their way
into your opponent's camp and if I
manage to bring this Knight to activate
it bring it to E6 then to G5 check the
king this Pawn on H4 despite the fact
that it's doubled is going to be become
a real real uh issue for white well
that's actually quite true the transfer
of the Knight to the king side there is
kind of scary uh no I agree with the
Knight on D6 and this is an idea we kept
talking about bringing the Knight to D6
and I mean I was just looking like the
Knight on A5 looks more dangerous
because you're not letting your
opponent's Knight just run around yeah
the question in many of the variations
that he's pointing out Christian is
pointing out wasn't played by the way
King D7 now uh I can play a move such as
E5 and I think I managed to maintain
stability in the position problem with
the move E5 is that all white can
possibly hope for now is a draw yeah I
mean that was my question when you say
stability you're saying like a draw draw
yeah yeah yeah but I mean this is not
what they
needed but he's he's very close to
overpress this position and actually
lose it yeah if I take only five you
cannot take with the Knight right cuz
I'm just going to play Knight C7 Knight
D5 just take your pawns let look at this
well you can just easily take on B4
immediately that might that might be an
easier
solution this is the time of the day
Knight F Knight F7 was played guys and
this is just losing oh is this a medal
winning or E5 five wait what why is E5
so strong let's explain it to the
audience what do you do I by the
audience I mean can you explain it to me
yeah
E55 uh so first E4 e takes takes an E4
yeah yeah oh Pawn your Pawn B4 is gonna
H oh and then I cannot take on E5
because let's go back a move okay if you
take on E5 I me it's a free Pawn uh King
E6 is not so much of a free Pawn mhm
King E7 oring e77 King E7 here now we
take with the Knight and then we go back
to the same position and who's going to
defend before this is very problematic
who's going to defend B4 in this
position look at this Pawn on this
Square this Knight on D D6 is is so
stupid what play Knight what is this
Knight doing on D6 this is uh did not
handle the position very well wow but
this is incredible what a turnaround if
he finds E5 it we're in serious trouble
and Jeffrey only has six minutes on the
clock yeah look at that clock situation
E5 is such a strong move do you think
he's going to find it he's it's
definitely on his radar natural it is
King E7 king7 I mean I think he might
just be happy with well he can just
repeat it once but I don't think think I
don't think je is going to play back to
F7 he might be happy with the draw but
on King D7 I don't think he'll be back
black lost a golden opportunity there I
I can still play E5 here oh but okay
it's not that it's not the same right
it's not the same it's not as powerful
still good E5 is still a good move in
this position but playing it in the
previous one with the Knight on
F7 o because the N Out s is just so
misplaced so mised it's almost trapped I
mean go back to the one of the problems
when you're being on the defensive like
all the time is that it's very difficult
to psychologically shift gears and
actually play for a for a win he was on
the on the back foot for the whole game
he's playing on uh three rows the eighth
the seventh and the sixth row and that's
it uh he's maneuvering his pieces around
that space and it's very very difficult
to play for a win when psychologically
you've been pressed the whole game yeah
I think any big shift in the evaluation
is very hard to handle psychologically
no matter if it's you're going from
losing to winning or from winning to
losing or from winning to like equal
even that is hard to handle let's see if
we can recover psychologically and see a
path towards win but I want to check out
some of the other games okay let's go to
savan game see if we had oh we do have a
oh so we have a repetition so let's see
if is this wait this is the second one
or this is the second so now King E7
would be a three-fold repetition really
but uh yeah after 96 well you're going
to play 96 right right uh if he plays E5
no King E7 is going to be the second
time is it the second time Miss counting
this is I think one time oh so we had
this from a while back okay two yeah
yeah it would be the third repetition
okay so now he's when you're in a
situation like this you can think about
and see if you want to uh well E5 would
be a really dangerous position here for
black he knows he might be able to find
something better let's take a look at po
guy can coun a break yesterday he lost
really B today if he draws he miss the
win yes it's like cannot make the
correct decision okay let's take a look
at the S game not much uh change this
Knight however on E2 it's not where he
want it to be why did the Knight go into
to can we go back yeah I'm kind of
curious as well Rook A8 which was what
Christian's
suggestion Rook F5 attacking the pawn on
E5 but that cuts the idea yeah it cuts
the Knight out of the way I really
wanted the Knight on F5 sh D4 okay
Knight E2 wait couldn't I play Knight E4
then you could but I don't know what the
follow oh I don't have the Rook F6
because I don't have the Rook lift
anymore no you don't so Knight E2 uh
Queen C6 and this is the current
position on the board taking on D4 will
just lead to an immediate draw but I'm
not sure what else you're going to do I
mean you did put a knight on E2 I'm
assuming that you wanted to okay to take
my
Bishop um wait so well I cannot if I
take your bishop and don't win a pawn I
don't think I want to do that because
I'm just giving you a pass Pawn I have
back rank issues you do have a back rank
issue that's why the move Queen C7 was
played to play Rook E1 uh with checkmat
so D4 is currently poisoned I mean this
is obviously just a draw you can play
most moves and this is a draw and with
the Knight on uh E2 I can just stay on
the diagonal with the bishop I think
because I don't my king is not under
attack anymore because your knight on E2
not E4 or H5 so so C1 was played uh
again putting pressure here on Black's
position he's going to keep trying he's
going to keep trying there's no reason
to give up just yet let's see the yeah
the RO game see wow that's a lot of
craziness and choa with two minutes on
the clock I ran Chopra against rang Le
only two minutes for the Indian player
in this position uh what we have a huge
mess I don't even know what's going on
let's take a look back we I was like H3
like a c you have to defend the pawn
yeah so we left all the way back here
after Knight F6 B5 was actually played
instead of the move that we expected
Knight B3 simplifying the situation here
but of course uh this oh sacrificing a
pawn sacrific really you take back on F3
strong word yeah you exchange some
pawns check and King H2 and H3 and this
is how we ar arose this position black
St great to fix the structure on the
other hand material is now very reduced
I would definitely take BL in this
position with a safer king and the a
superior situation on the clock but is
so reduced that I'm trying to figure out
if I could actually create any real
threats I'm not sure how much safer your
king is because you cannot really move
your knight because you always have some
back growing issues mhm Bishop H1 was
played Bishop F1 almost immediately
blade because you have to defend here
the Checkmate threats on the G2 Square
so how do you defend your Pawn or do you
defend your Pawn maybe a queen oh I
don't want to play Queen F3 because then
my Bishop's
trapped yeah you don't want to play play
this queen here almost ever cuz this you
lose coordination completely yeah4 yeah
finding finding a next move is not so
clear something like even Knight D4
Knight D6 it's not so clear to tr next
okay so how do we defend the pawn how do
we defend the
pawn um good question huh it's not very
clear maybe I just have to go back with
the bishop and attack your knight oh but
um and then Knight D4
kn4 I was hoping I could use some kind
of pin
Queen
A7 maybe wait and then I take your p and
I'm I'm hoping I I don't know I didn't
say I found anything I was just hoping
that I have something well but worst
case scenario I can go Bishop no no then
you're no I mean now just exchanging
everything uh I don't I don't see much I
mean if I lose the pawn on F4 this is
the current position if I lose the pawn
on F4 wh King feels a lot safer than it
I'll put a queen on F2 my knight can
always go there I play Bishop G2 force
in exchange at some point yeah there's
not shouldn't be a lot of problems here
for uh the white side I think it's just
visual I don't think it's actually black
um white is is any danger you don't have
enough like you don't have anything to
do you can't do anything on the dark
squares you don't have a dark Square
Bishop like if you had a dark Square
Bishop I would just die here but don't I
agree with you this do this looks more
visual than anything else I don't see
any problems with White's position
perhaps the engine can find something
but no the position is completely equal
guys and and I actually have a moment of
truth for you guys this is for the gold
medal uh after the move H3 there is only
one way that black can maintain the
initiative and keep the position
unbalanced keep the material on the
board let's see who's going to get the
gold
medal um to keep the position on
Bal okay so let's see so I need to
sacrifice something so actually in the
game he did play move Bishop C6 so we're
expecting knight4 or maybe I I think
Knight D6 is it's a little bit
counterintuitive that's all intuitive
okay allely intuitively I look at checks
forward
moves the Knight doesn't have actually
have a move in this
position does it it's a counter
intuitive move so it's some kind of a
backwards
move so it's with the
bishop no is it would Bish of
Christian this is for the gold medal and
you want me to give you anything yes
I'll settle for silver medal absolutely
no hints absolutely no hints uh okay so
let's see so Queen check doesn't do
anything Queen attacking Bishop doesn't
do
anything um counter intuitive moves I
don't know can I sacrifice on G4 no ah
Bishop
D5 yes Bishop to D take the bishop in
that position would have made maintain
the initiative keep the pieces on the
board after you Retreat the bishop I
always have the idea of playing F3
defend that pawn very close to your king
your king is going to always feel unsafe
because of this action uh on the long on
the A7 G1 diagonal the dark Square
diagonal the position is still very
close to equality but uh with one minute
on the clock keeping this Pawn alive was
crucial and unfortunately ruy Fang
played the move Bishop H1 which as you
guys mentioned was the visual move to uh
threaten immediate Checkmate on G2 but
after Bishop F1 simply your pieces are
uncoordinated and uh the pawn on F4 is
falling so yes Bishop D5 would have been
the right move after Bishop takes D5
this would have been game over on the
spot because of Queen takes B5 and now
you don't have any way of getting out of
this very very dangerous pin on the
fifth rank Queen B8 doesn't work Queen
E8 doesn't work uh you're going to lose
the bishop and the game uh this would
have been very very difficult to deal
with over the board but congratulations
Alejandro uh you've earned your
medal big big developments in the
Jeffrey Jean game uh hi M did play E5 he
did not repeat the position he's going
for the win he smells it he knows that
something's already gone horribly wrong
for Jeffrey he plays move E5 D takes E5
and on the board we have the move that
the computer was suggesting King E7 we
have this position already yeah and this
Knight on F7 it doesn't have a way back
into the game I need to defend this
point on4 it is so far away from it it
is just so far away from it and at this
point that wherever the Knight moves I'm
going to take on E5 with the Knight and
then that removes the only defender of
the B4 pawn and the rest I think is just
toast this is not a good day for Team
USA and the Knight doesn't even have
that many squares to go to either D6 or
okay H6 is just kind of ridiculous you
have to go to D6 and 85 just looks very
very bad looks losing yeah I think the
end game has turned around completely it
was funny because we're saying it's
almost impossible for white to lose it's
a two old game he managed he managed to
find way try like he made um like he
made a lot of mistakes to get here it's
not like black out played him no he just
just outplayed himself basically
basically yeah I mean we're losing or us
team is already losing by one point so
if um hi M also wins then they at least
guaranteed a tie but I think based on
the results on the positions on the
board if hike M does convert the
position world team is going to win
because there's no way both Chopra and
Andre ASO are going to lose against
rangley and Sam savan so today is not U
morning is not a good morning for Team
USA not this one at the very least
because things are looking awful we do
have a move from Jeffrey which I really
don't think helps him very much the move
E6 I'm pretty sure I just take this Pawn
I don't see the big difference you
basically get to the same position so
you're going to play knight8 I'm going
to play going to play Knight I'm going
King E7 the Knight still going to have
to go here of taking a pawn and just got
to the same position and we this
happening yeah this is a very basic uh
continuation and uh you know I have to
say like I thought with two rounds a day
Team USA would be doing much better they
should be more used to it but I have to
give a lot of credit for um our visitors
our guests because I think it's really
hard I think a lot of people who come
play in the US for the first time I mean
we we cover a lot of events in this
tournament and all of them are like high
class events the US Championship the
singfield cup the even The Showdown well
the show down is like raping and bled so
it's a little different but all these
major events that we host here in the
whole Grand Chester it's one round the
day it's very ear tournament but a lot
of the tournaments in the US are to
around the day and longer time controls
so sometimes you literally have 30
minutes and that have happened to me I'm
sure to you Chris all of us have 30
minutes between games you just go you
eat something and then you're sitting
down to your next game and like you feel
heavy in your sumach CU you just feel
finished itting I lost 40 rating points
in the first maybe six months in the
united stat I I when I moved here I was
very very young so I don't think I was
very affected by it I was only 13 but a
lot of players say that when they first
come to play in the US it's very
difficult for them but this players are
very young so perhaps it's not a big
issue for them and Jeffrey is going for
that uh Pawn on H4 he played this move
Knight to H6 with the idea to jump back
to F5 and potentially recover this Pawn
on H4 the problem is that after Knight
to E5 I'm annihilating the defender of
the Pawn on B4 this is just a game over
I'm not really sure how he's going to
continue he play KN F4 sh Knight check
okay I'm going to put my king let's say
to D7 so no checks on the board you're
going to take let's say this uh this
Pawn I'm just simply going to take on B4
and how are you going to stop this uh B
Pawn how are you going to defend the C5
Pawn after a move such as Knight to D3
this is just something something that's
more important is that sometimes
nightend games you yeah you don't know
how you're going to step up on but you
have the counter play of something else
the problem is that there is no counter
play there is nothing that white can do
in this position taking a pawn and
passing it here takes so long your
Knights are very badly placed and once
again we go to uh the quality of the
pieces the Knight on E5 is perfectly
placed perfectly poised to support that
B4 pawn and not allow the knight from F4
to get back into the game uh the Knight
on A6 he was stuck the whole game but
right now he has a very active role he's
going to take on B4 um this
is very very sad position for uh white
black is going to repeat moves once and
then he's going to have to find uh the
right way or just go King F deflecting
King black has more time why is black
the one repeating moves well it doesn't
really matter at this point I think good
technique could increase uh your chances
if you had more time because remember
that they're both in time pressure you
want to play for the position MH and I
think here after Knight H6 check um you
can either go King G7 or King f8
immediately there you go King f8 he
knows that the pawn on B4 is going to be
hanging he knows that this is a very
important game he knows that this is his
recovery after the disaster that he had
yesterday I think hike smells blood in
the water he's coming after our top
player Jeffrey Shong and he has all the
resources for him to win a crucial game
here and this is the best way to recover
beting the highest rated player the
current world uh World Junior Champion
yeah Jeffrey je was a member of our
world team team he was part of our
Olympic team he played in the world team
one of the strongest player in the US of
course even with this tough loss he
didn't play the best game still one of
the best players in the US what a like
what a great way to recover after that a
silly blunder basically no I mean like
when you lose a game like that I mean
you feel bad but then you feel like it's
not a reflection of your play obviously
it's like your mind just turned off for
a second it's not like oh my God I'm
such a bad player I didn't understand
the position or like I couldn't
calculate like your mind just turned out
for a moment and just B
so King takes H4 and I'm assuming this
Pawn B4 is not going to live for very
long there's a reason not to take it
after which white is going to
immediately try to create some kind of
weird counterplay against the pawn on F6
but promise it comes a little bit too
slow it doesn't really achieve that much
it kind of Tangles your own Knights the
example Knight takes
B4 uh where is my knight on
A6 this mouse is not cooperating sorry
guys Knight
H5 Knight
H5 and here the problem among well many
others is that if I just play the move
Knight bd3 Christian was mentioning how
amazing this Knight on E5 is and the
reason is that it's blocking up very
important Pawn on e4 because if I had to
waste my time and bring my king to
defend the pawn on F6 things are not so
clear the knights might create a
counterplay but if I just give up my
Pawn if I just give up my pawn and this
Pawn this is remains blocking the E4
Pawn You've Won what I could consider to
be a completely inconsequential pawn and
even if you win the H7 Pawn like I have
so many pieces there's no like your own
pieces are in the way and my king is in
front of it so this just looks game over
yeah while before you just it just goes
yeah he did take on before before and
yeah so that's the position we had so
it's white turn to try to figure out
what he's going to do and it's
absolutely done I mean Jeffrey has a
good poker face so we don't know how he
feels I think he has a good Poker Face
and I'm actually eyeing the Sam savian
position and I do not like what to see
because I see a Pawn on D3 well luckily
for us this is the Sam savian position
against Andre is aseno uh he is up Aon
let's give him that much he is up Aon in
this position so he should not be in any
real danger next one move because Queen
takes E3 is coming on the board oh so we
do have a result in the Chopra versus
Lee game looks like a draw to me because
game really nothing to wow so this looks
like uh the world team is going take
this match yeah absolutely uh Queen
takes A3 and okay all the pawns were
annihilated only one part of the word to
play in an easy draw there haran choer
is the rang I wouldn't say great chances
for either side to win at any given
point uh s position okay yeah Sans
against Andre aseno this is the current
position also here I don't consider
there to be any real danger for Sam uh
you can just pile on the D pawn and
black has no choice but to pile on the
defense so nothing much should happen in
this position you just keep attacking
the Deep Pawn while to keep defending
and Def you just Shuffle back and forth
there's really nothing to do wow what a
what a bad day what a bad day we're
going to be U minus two for the day as
we got absolutely crushed on board four
with Nicholas CA losing to Sara and here
Jeffrey Shan just over pushing or
pushing carelessly I would say is more
accurately just was pushing carelessly
against a hike Marty rosan who takes
advantage of the
situation yeah and is going to emerge up
with a huge win here jeffy's gears are
turning trying to figure out how not to
lose immediately how not to let the pawn
on the B5 Square Queen in just a few
more moves he needs to at least keep the
game alive but he knows even that task
is difficult to achieve down to two
minutes is Jeffrey Shan this looks very
bad yeah this this looks like a matter
of
time you don't have counter play you
cannot use your Knights to do absolutely
anything against my king it's going to
take forever to grab any Pawns of mine
and uh creating a pass Pawn that's just
a fantasy this is just game over Knight
D3 B4 B3 B2 game over and Tick Tock
there goes okay knight6 check play the
check King E7 nice King E7 or King E8
seem completely
normal so I guess the Knight is going to
the center D4 to let's try to stop the
pawn for the time being for the time
being but king7 right away so Knight D4
right away Knight D4 right away and now
I would expect Knight bd3 can just take
the pawn right targets the C5 pawn and
helps me push the pawn on the B file uh
and as we have already mentioned there
is no counterplay that's a big problem
there is no thing that uh H has to be
worried about there's no Pawn on the H
file there's no potential counterplay
with a pass Pawn you're BS on the king
side are pretty safe yeah and the two
minutes to seven minutes uh the time
differential is uh pretty significant
it's very significant here the
differential in pawns the differential
in time we're talking about a very
difficult position here for Jeffrey Shan
I don't think he has any realistic
chance to save it against a player as
strong as Mar and Knight D3 was Knight
bd3 was played and once you take the C5
Pawn it's just game over that's two
pawns two free connected pass pawns
rolling down the board onto the first
rank unbelievable that Jeffrey would
lose in this fashion uh don't matter who
he was playing it just felt like he was
pressing pressing pressing at some point
he gave up a pawn for free on H4 a
strange decision and then his transfer
of the knight from A5 to D6 wow what a
Str G5 I think he did play G5 yes G5 was
played so I'm assuming take on Knight
C5 and so we're assuming is going to
take take on C5 and then E4 is going to
hang so we're assuming this game is
going to be over pretty soon I mean they
he's he has 2 minutes so he's going to
keep playing because why not you know
you have uh so little time so we're
going to keep an eye on this game but in
the meantime we do have an interview
with Arian Chopra who is in the studio
with
Christian with one of the most solid
players in the world team a rock for
that team uh Arian welcome back to the
show um did you feel at any moment in
the game in danger today
M no not really I I thought the position
after the opening was close to equal but
afterwards he took some risks and he
wanted to attack with this F Pawn and he
wanted to play E5 so I thought then I
had some winning chances because like
his King was unsafe also my king was not
very safe but it was very unclear
position so
I had less time I mean not I was not in
time trouble but compared to him I had
less time so um the there were many
exchanges and then it was soon a draw
and you feel like uh this strategy of
his to try to overpress try to unbalance
the position at all costs uh came
because of the match situation because
uh San uh for your team won his game
very very
quickly I I don't
know I don't know really uh I thought
okay he he played a sharp variations so
I thought he wanted to win from the
beginning so I also had winning chances
and tell us what is the strategy overall
uh surrounding your team do you guys
meet at night have board meetings uh
plan the strategy for next round yes you
do well very very organized work team
and uh right now they're definitely
leading with authority this tournament
guys back to you yeah already a plus
three score on the overall for the Royal
team and it should be a plus4 soon as I
do not like jeffy's position I don't
know why his opponent has given up the
F6 Pawn for free but it shouldn't change
the character of the position wait what
happened after G5 he took on C5 so is
there some a problem with taking on G5
no I mean I think everything was winning
I don't see any problem with what he's
done or with f takes G5 okay so what are
he doing takes on C on C5 Knight G8 uh
King I think he played a two F7 and
Knight takes F6 this is the current
decision um so what's the plan now I'm
assuming B4 B3 B2 is a good plan yeah I
agree quinning a pawn sounds good um
okay but let's start so before if I take
canot have to give up a knight yeah the
only thing you have to be careful is not
to give the other Pawn away uh because
two knights can't make a long King so
that's true except if there's some
exceptions with a pawn but I'm not I
don't want to get into that uh so
actually I had a discussion about this I
think if the Knight if like on the fifth
rank in front of the pawn already it's
like you can win and actually I saw a
game um you know H new Neiman Neiman
yeah yeah yeah like I saw a game that he
had two knights and like the Knight was
stopping one of the pawns and then the
other night like zuk Zang the king
basically and the other night so basic
so he check yeah he checkm made it by
allowing his opponent to quen and I
didn't know that was possible oh
definitely yeah yeah but there's like
certain positions if there was just a
draw because the opponent is too
advanced but okay there's no need to get
there's no I think there is one very
easy way to win this game and that is uh
play the move Knight to E6 this Knight
on D4 is very the most powerful piece in
White's Cam he's for the moment stopping
Black's uh uh march on the B file and if
you exchange obviously after Knight
takes King takes E6 Knight takes H when
your knight is way out of the game I'm
going to go B4 B3 B2 and there's no way
you're going to stop that my knight on
E5 is perfectly guarding this Pawn on G5
so there's never a way for you to try to
promote and uh after Knight E6 if you
try to play a move such as uh Knight C2
to still stop the pawn I have this move
H6 now you cannot take on H6 because
Knight on F6 is hanging I'm going to
grab another Pawn I'm going to be two
pawns up two connected passers up and
that's just going to be game over or and
has played Knight E6 kayak has found uh
the correct continuation and that's
that's it I think uh if the move Knight
F5 is played on the board I also have
the simple idea of playing Knight F3
check and Knight takes G5 if uh I don't
see any other tactics so it looks pretty
good and I can also just go B4 and push
my Pawn so after Knight E6 which I think
was a key move I think the rest comes
rather simply yeah and without the
Knight on D4 that B4 Pawn is um
Unstoppable yeah it's a sad day here for
team said at least a sad morning let's
see if they can recover in the afternoon
round because this is not going well Sam
San game is definitely going and skiing
towards a draw nothing can really happen
in that position so we're expecting a
3-1 result in the morning in the favor
of a world team yeah they're going to be
four points ahead of us ahead of the US
with three matches to go that's
significant yes and the evening round I
don't think is going to be much better
for Team
USA there is the under 14 section which
is um which is a a challenging uh
section for us and actually we do have a
result in Sam saavan uh they drew the
game so officially the match is over
because the score oh no so I'm sorry the
score is 21 still so it's not over yet
but um this is the score we're expecting
so the match is basically over because
there's no way hi can ever lose this
position no no way no way no we cannot
win it either yeah 3-1 is the score
we're expecting so a very very tough day
for Team USA and yeah I don't think it's
um I know it sounds a little green but I
don't think it's going to improve in the
evening yeah because that is where we
are out rated we were hoping today with
two whites in the top boards Jeffrey sha
with white Sam Sean with white this was
the time to strike and actually it would
be interesting to hear from Team USA if
they also have like team meetings or
anything because they do have the
coaches they have the campus but I
wonder what their team chemistry is like
because I do feel like the world team
has great team chemistry and when I was
listening to their interviews like P
amand I would say you know like they
felt the responsibility to say sometimes
you have to play sharp sometimes you
have to play solid so they they do have
a strategy coming to the game which I
think sometimes can backfire because
when you come into a game Thinking okay
we need to make four draws you cannot
you you cannot predict the result of the
game before the game starts but I do
think it's a good idea that everyone's
kind of on the same page of U what
they're trying to achieve and they had a
a few days cap here with FL with
Alexander on his CH with
Aman Gary CASRO himself came to train
them for a little bit seems sometimes
the training may may have tired them out
because right now they're not producing
the results that one would have expected
especially in the under 17 section yeah
under 17 section is the section that we
thought us would be dominating but you
know I have to give props to the world
team that are playing really good chess
yeah very good chess and they're going
to be up uh three points in the under 17
Four Points in the overall I mean the
they've gotten some gifts but they also
handed some gifts so it's not like their
points are just uh a little gift in take
yeah no I mean they have they've earned
a lot of nice wins they've saved some
positions and um every Point I've earned
has been their they earned has been U
well deserved and we still have some
moves um H5 but after Pawn takes G5 I
think you're almost getting M actually
I'm a little confused by King H5 well
you don't have a move H H G5 is going to
come when the I would expect something
like Knight H7
maybe but then G4 everything's winning I
mean it just doesn't matter you can lose
the G5 on for free and it's still
winning so once again that Knight on E5
simply won the game oh he played Knight
G5 it doesn't really matter at this
point I think yeah the Knight on5 is a
beautiful piece and I think he there he
goes have the handshake there's the
handshake and it's official uh the world
team has won the morning round 3 to one
a really disappointing result here for
Jeffrey Shan with the white pieces that
high rated player and having a
comfortable position in which he can try
to press for the win for a very long
time turn around
completely one of those end games that
you almost never see a Grandmaster lose
I mean almost never see I would lose
that end game very easily as white huh
as white as both I mean first don't
sound surprised there's a 2640 rated
person lost game it's not all possible
besid happen in front of our eyes yeah
which is still surprising oh KN G5
actually does drop the night I just
realized that
too you don't have any you have to play
night G4 and lose all your pawns well
props to Marty rosian he did take on e4
uh he exchanged the pawn from D5 to to
the pawn on e4 he changed the character
of the position he took that risk and uh
it simply paid off and that
psychological strength to as you guys
were mentioning that you're defending
defending defending and sometimes you
you don't notice that you've been giving
winning chances because you were just
defending and defending and somebody
offers you a draw you're like great this
is what I've been wanting for hours but
no he was offered a draw with the
three-fold repetition and he said hold
on wait a second let me look at this
position and he realized that there was
that chance to win he played E5 when it
was necessary and he won uh exactly how
he needed to win yeah and he bounced
back from that very tough loss yesterday
and but we mentioned that the loss a
loss like that is not reflective of your
chest just uh a blind
side well let's take a look at what
happened today another bloody day for
the US team and the 3 to1 is actually a
very big margin to lose by so H marus
and coming back uh from his defeat
yesterday winning a really nice game
against Jeffrey Jan Andre esipenko
drawing some savan holding the position
which we thought some had some chances
Arian choa and Ru Ang Lee Aran Cho we
thought the position was very Dynamic
but Arian made it sound so easy like
there was no problem everything was so
natural no danger just an easy draw and
Alexa sarana winning that uh very easy
game against Nicholas cha which I think
just set the whole thing in motion and
now
the in the under 17 section the score
the team score is 8 and 1 half to 11 and
A2 in the favor of the world team and in
the under 14 section they haven't played
any games yet so it's still three in a
half to four and a half so the current
standings is uh us team has 12 points
and the world team has 16 points so the
US the world team is leing by Four
Points there is so many points yeah I
mean there's still three matches left
two of them are the double uh rounds
with the under 14 and the under 17 still
playing but there's 20 points left to
play for and I mean I mean that that is
a big difference I mean I I almost want
to say the world already want this but
it's a little premature we'll see the
lock in happen let's have some f on our
under 14s today they've been fighting
very very strong chest especially the
girls have been keeping uh up with their
opponents so I want to see if they're
able to do so again today and perhaps
even surpass them why not I mean I don't
want to take anything away from our us
team but I do have to give a lot of
credit to the world team because they
are I think they are very very
impressive in this tournament and it's
like I'm not
t we're not talking down on the US team
it's just the praise for the world team
because they are defeating one of the
best players in the world and um we're
done with the round for the for the
morning and we do have a round later on
in the day at 5:00 p.m. it was going to
be the double Round And as a reminder
tomorrow R will be starting an hour
earlier so we can accommodate for the
closing ceremony that will follow up the
last round of the tournament so we'll be
starting at at 9:00 a.m. tomorrow yeah
and we do have uh Christian K here with
one of the big winners of the Day hike
Marty rosan of Armenia
with uh the biggest Victor of today's
round after a very very difficult
struggle against Jeffrey Jong the leader
of the world team Haik Marti Roan Haik
welcome to the show and congratulations
for uh today's Victory uh what did you
do after yesterday's defeat yesterday's
defeat looked very painful uh it looked
like you just simply blunder and after
that there was no coming back uh what
did you do at night to get ready for
this important match yes it's very
interesting game and Jeffrey play uh win
because USA team lost at it's thr
position but he played G4 it's not good
at G4 G5 H4
GS I'm F this position you felt like he
over pressed in in in the game yes
uh um I like
[Music]
foree uh he said he spent a lot of time
thinking about the game yesterday uh
like kind of dwelling over it but he
pulled himself together and decided he
was going to do whatever he can to come
through for the team today did you guys
uh have a team meeting last night with
the captain
what was the strategy and overall the
atmosphere in the team going into this
morning's
gamee
foreign M did
you so he said that they have a great
atmosphere in the team after the games
they get together they discuss the games
together and they try to encourage
together and they actually also prepare
together and also the player that seats
out every round uh does he help you with
the openings does he help everybody in
the team with their openings uh what is
his role well uh I mean
uh
foree
[Music]
spee just
rest
congratulations great performance and
good luck in the rest of your
games guys uh hi Marty rosan the world
uh team leader back to you yeah the the
top rated player here in the world team
showing that he has the Psy olical
strength to bounce back from an
atrocious loss to beat the strongest
player in the competition and with the
black pieces yeah and then I said
they're like 17 years old they don't
have uh they shouldn't have any
psychological problems but of course no
but of course it's always tough to
recover from a win and we said it's
tough to recover from
uh no from a loss and sometimes it's
tough to recover from a win but I do
like it does sound like the world team
has great chemistry and um they get
together and it's like they spend all
their time together and it's worked out
perfectly here Christian any final
thoughts here on today's round well
there is only one final thought and that
is the Americans need to pull together
uh be as resilient as ever and try to
come back into this match because so far
it's been just a struggle they're making
the wrong decision at every turn and uh
the big dogs Jeffrey Shong Sam Sean Ru
Fang Lee they're simply struggling and
uh Nicholas czecho on the fourth board
uh Burke uh they're not finding
themselves in this tournament it might
be that they are simply exhausted after
playing uh for the past six months
almost non-stop every single player but
uh they need to do something they need
to have a strategy going into this uh
last three rounds and uh simply pull
together and try uh to come back this is
uh so far a route for the world
team yeah today was uh this morning was
another tough day for Team USA losing
the second match in a row as they did
lose yesterday against the world team
and uh as Christian mentioned it's going
to be a tough rad ahead for Team USA but
it's still not over there's still three
rounds to go there's still a lot of
games to be played so everyone thank you
for joining us and don't forget at 5:00
p.m. we're going to have another round
the under 14 team is going to be playing
as well so we're going to have eight
games going on we don't know uh we don't
know the pairings I believe for the next
round for under 17 because they do have
a
Reserve player so they're going to
decide who they're going to sit out so
please make sure you're tuning at 5:00 P
pm to see the second round of the
[Music]
day